In-app navigation:  Principals
Principles and recommendations
Navigation:  Principles and
Recommendations.
At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
>> Good morning. Thanks for
getting up early to be here
with us even despite the fact
that some
of our thunder may have been
stolen by
the 3 or 4 presentations before
this that demoed the navigation
editor.  We have time to go into
a little more
detail than any of the previous
presentations so there's a lot
of good material here.
I'm Lukas Bergstrom and with me
I have
Ian and Sergey who built the
navigation component.
Navigation if you think about it
is a prop that pretty much every
app on Android has to solve but
until now we haven't really
given you anything to do that
with other than start activity
which for various reasons is not
the
best way to go about that.
So if you think about our job of
making Android development
easier, navigation
was a common problem with no
real solution and that means
that there are a lot of things
that you have to solve on your
own.
And those range from how to
commit fragment transactions,
hopefully without
throwing an exception, how to
test the navigation is happening
correctly and
that the right things are
happening when
navigation occurs, how to map
deep links to various places in
your app and how to deep those
deep link schemes up to date as
your app navigational structure
chaels.
Passing arguments from place to
place.  Again we don't give you
a type safe way to do that
today.
How to make sure that up and
back take users to the right
places particularly in sort of
more difficult situations
like someone deep linking deep
into your app's navigation
hierarchy.
And so what this means is by the
time you finish solving these
problems, you typically have
gone 1 of 2 directions.
You've either written 60% of a
navigation framework or you've
got a lot
of error prone boilerplate
everywhere a nave gags needs to
happen in your app.  You have a
bunch of parallel lines in
your code involving these
problems and the whole structure
is very brittle.  Oh, sorry.
And individually these problems
are pretty tractible but if you
look at a real world example you
can see that they can get pretty
hairy.
So say that I have an item
screen
saved in my app and
it's accessible via deep link
but if someone navigated to the
screen opening the app from the
home screen they would have a
couple other screens on the back
stack.
So hitting it up we want them to
take it not out of the app from
the screen,
we want them to go to the
category screen and then the
home screen.  If someone deep
links into the app we
need to synthesize these screens
and add
them to the up stack before
showing the screen.  It's when
you're in the middle of writing
the code to do this to
synthesize these screens and add
them to
the up and back stack but only
on a deep link, that's when you
start to feel like maybe you're
solving a failure of the
framework.
So it helps all problems like
that that we are launching
navigation.  What we are giving
you us a visual
tool that let's you edit the
navigation graph of your app
which is represented in XML.
And that let's you define a set
of available navigation actions,
arguments you can pass from
place to place, things like
visual transitions and a single
navigate call activates all that
at run time.
And so last but not least that
means one thing you never have
to worry about
again is torching
is touching a fragment
transaction with your bare
hands.  [Applause].
So the navigation graph is
essentially
just a set of what are the
possible destinations people can
reach in my app and those
usually correspond to screens
but not always.
So you can have the navigation
controller just changing the
contents of
a smaller part of the screen,
but it's a set of navigation
destinations and the actions
that link them.  And the actions
really represent how you can get
from place to place.
So to actually navigate from
point A to point B in an app,
you're going to call the correct
navigation action at run time.
So let's look at what this looks
like
and let's switch over to the
demo.  Okay.
So what we see here is a set of
navigation destinations and
these are fragment destinations
although other options are
possible.
And the lines connecting them
are arrow heads are actions.
And those actions actually
generate
methods you can call at run
time.
This whole thing is backed by
XML as you all know and love.
And the XML and the navigation
editor have the same set of
capabilities so you can use
either one.
We are going to add a screen
here.  And what you're seeing is
a set of available activities
and fragments in my app.  Okay.
So we just added an option for
them to actually answer this
question successfully and win
the game so now we
are going to add an action to
navigate to that screen.
Great.  And so that navigation
action has a bunch of options
that you can set, obviously.  We
are going to talk about those a
little bit more.  For now we are
going to do one thing.  We are
going to say if they have gotten
to this congratulations screen,
that means the game is over.  So
hitting back shouldn't take them
back into a game that no longer
exists.
So what that means is we want to
on
that action say let's pop to the
match screen and that means I'm
going to pop off everything on
the back stack in
between this destination and the
match screen.  So when the user
gets to the congratulations
screen, when they hit
back, they're just going to go
straight to the match screen.
So a lot of other options I can
set but I'll just talk about
that for now.
Let's go back and look at the
congratulations screen again.
One other thing to mention, the
key thing that is set here is
the fragment class.
And that's what is actually
instantiated a run time.
And we see layout previews here
because the navigation editor
know
what's layout is associated with
that
navigation graph, because it
knows, I can double click on
that fragment destination to get
here into the layout editor.
Great.  And everything that I've
just done
here adding this new destination
to the navigation graph, an
action changing what the pop
behavior of that action is, all
this stuff I can also do
programatically at run time.
So navigation editor, XML
or programatic all work just
fine.  Great.
And now I'm going to hand this
off to Ian to walk you through
some more detail.
>> IAN LAKE: So the first
question that
might come to mind is wow this
is a
totally new way of structuring
the UI and it brings up this
question
immediately so what is my
activity actually meant to do?
Every kind of app has a
different starting point from
where you guys are
right now or maybe as of two
days ago on how you kind of
struck your UI of your app.
Some may be very activity heavy,
fragment heavy, very much in a
different system.
All those are certainly valid
places to be but we are moving
towards a model where the
activity is more just an entry
point into your app rather than
the activity being the owner of
the content
of your app it's actually just
what is going to store that
global state.
So the global navigationss,
navigation
drawings, you're still using an
action bore, those are things
that activities
manage but it delegates to what
we call a nav host for content.
So our nice super simple
activity here.
We have a action bar on the top,
a bottom nav on the bot.
This is our nav host n the world
of navigation when you navigate
between different destinations
in your app we are replacing
everything inside that box so
you have that global navigation
outside of that and we have
hooks that you can
hook that up to stay in sync
with the actual nav host.  What
does a super simple version of
this look like?  If you are
using fragment ors
destinations
s you'll want to your our nav
host
fragment
.  You do this by including the
navigation fragment dependency.
If you're using a totally
different kind of destination it
will probable I also have a
different kind of nav host
that you add here.  But for now
post fragment we set up a few
convenience methods.
The ability to set what
navigation graph you're using in
XML so you don't need to do
anything programatically to set
it up.  It will just go to the
start
destination of your graph by
default.  For fragments we can
hook this up to the system back
button so we offer a method to
do exactly that.
So you don't have to override on
that specifically for
navigation.
We will hook up all that stuff
using the magic of fragments
through this default nav host
option.
That means that our activity
actually gets to be two lines of
code.
It would be two lines but it
doesn't fit horizontally on the
slide.
But all we need to do is just
inflate
our layout, set content view and
hook up the up button.
Because you told us about this
structure of your graph, in this
case we
are using
a column extension method that
allows
us to find the navigation
controller bypassing in the ID.
And that gives us access to
navigate up.  And navigate up is
going to do the right thing
based on your navigation graph.
You done need to actually do a
lot of
extra work't need to actually do
a lot of extra work here by
giving us your graph.  We are
able to do this for you.
But for most apps just having a
single thing is not actually
what you have.  Maybe you have
something a little bit more.
So we have kind of set up a
second dependency, navigation-ui
which is really just a set of
static methods that connect your
navigation component with some
of the material design
components.
Some of the things like bottom
nav and
things that are very much in
that global
navigation space but of course
it's 2018 so we have KTX one
that changes those static
methods into
extension methods so it's really
easy
for users to integrate to your
app and have navigation feel
just like it's something that
exists.
Of so what does this look likeSo
what does this look like?
If we make our activity a little
bit
more complicated, add a Toolbar
on the top and a bottom
navigation view.  We still have
the same app menu that you had
before on a bottom navigation
view but what we do to hook
those things up it takes two
parts.  One, your menu here is
actually going to be using the
same ID's that you've had on
each destination.  Each
destination has a unique ID and
we can use those same ID's on
your menu items.
So that build an implicit link
of if you click the home menu
item you're going to go to the
home destination of your app.
In cold we are going to set up
our action bore using our tool
bore.
And we can do the same find nav
controller to get our access to
the nav controller object.
And then we just have a column
extension for activity that
allows you
to set up bar with nav
controller.
This does quite a bit of magic.
What it's doing is receiving
events on when you navigated in
your nav controller and using
the labels that you set up in
your navigation graph to update
the title of your action bar.
We also have another helper
method if you're using a drawer
layout to automatically change
it from a hamburger button into
a back arrow based on what
destination you're on.
Really those helpful patterns to
make
sure those things stay in sync.
Similarly for the bottom nav you
call set up and redo the two-way
thinking here.  As you click on
things in the bottom nav it will
change the graph and do the
correct transition based on the
material guidelines as well as
as you navigate between your app
if you have separate buttons it
will update the selected item
in the bottom navigation.
So this givers this gives us a
lot of
power but not everyone is using
prebuilt components that another
team did.  You have your own
custom UI.
We have to go deeper into what
nav controller actually gives
us.  You have a button, you want
it to go somewhere.
We have the convenience method,
create on click listener.  You
give it the ID of where you want
it to go, what action you want
it to trigger and we will do all
the work for you.  This is
perhaps a little too magical
so you can unroll it just a
little bit.
In this case we are using
another extension method on
view.
So from any view that's been
created
by nav controller, you can
actually get
a reference to your nav
controller just
by calling find nav controller
as you
might expect and use that nav
controller
to call navigate and just
navigate to an ID of a
destination or an action in your
graph.
That's it.  Under the covers
this navigate is actually doing
a lot of work.  So the nav
controller is talking to what we
call a Navigator.
So
So for fragments we are talking
to a fragment Navigator.  It's
going to build all of the
fragment transactions for you.
It's going to do all the things
you told us to do by putting
that information in your
navigation graph.
So if you have had pop up, it's
going
to do all that stuff,
transitions, all that in this
one line of code.
All of it can be either
programatically or something
that you
determine ahead of time as part
of your navigation graph.
But for a lot of these kinds of
places
it's not actually just a
navigate.  You have some
information to pass to the next
source.
So for this we need to pass a
bundle of information.
Here we are passing a string and
an int and using our nice
helpful bundle
from AndroidKtx and it works.
It's fine.
This is really useful for a lot
of
things but at the same point
it's not very safe.
If you do a miss type here, what
are you going to do?  We want to
make this a lot easier so we
will talk about what we did
here.
>> We build something called
safe Args Gradle plugin.  First
let's see what they're trying to
resolve.  Let's go back to our
sample.
Our fragment where we tried to
negate
actually requires us the best
screen name argument.
Best category which has integer
type.  Let's go back to the
calling site.  Well in our
slides we made everything
correctly.
We passed
screen, but actually
you can forget the best screen
name.  It's a result in run time
exception.
It's super easy to fix but it's
still
annoying.  I don't know.  Okay.
Now we have this navigation
graph.
Let's put all our navigation
there including the arguments
for destinations.
Let's see how it looks in XML.
And super simple.
We just specify your argument
name,
its type
.  And this allows us to build
two links that once you have an
action that lists
to this fragment or other action
or
activity, we can check and make
the best proper argument also.
So let's take a look at how its.
So let's take a look at how it
looks.
Now we use this special object
which
instead of passing ID in a
bundle, of course internally the
subject incorporates the same ID
and same
arguments but to get this object
we use
home fragment direction class,
it's generated for you.
It's just a fragment name plus
static directions.  It has
static methods for this
destination.
And those static methods may
have required arguments.
In our case it makes us the best
home
argument there and later it can
set up
your other additional arguments.
And then everything is type
safe.
And after that it's super
simple.
You have
this, it's Args class.
For our case is help fragment
Args.
And it's all your arguments that
you defined in a type set
manner.
And for this small improvement
we go
to the bigger one which is deep
links.
>> IAN LAKE: Yes. Deep links
are traditionally something that
Android has supported for a long
time.
You can take over a web URL, as
well as deep linking a super
useful for notifications and
things like that to link back
into your app.
But it gets a lot more
complicated as you get a more
complicated app like how you
structure these things and how
you say all right I need to
build a notification, what is
all of the code that is needed
to actually get into the correct
place in my app and pass the
right kind of information here?
So for navigation we really made
deep
linking a kind of class citizen
in our structure.
So there's really two kinds of
deep links.
The explicit kind, these are the
things like for notifications,
app
shortcuts, app widgets tan new
actions and slices.
Things that you create and are
usually pending and tent based.
These are things you're passing
to
another app or system to say I
want to go to this specific
place in my app.  The implicit
side of things are more
around the web URLs and custom
scheme URLs.  These are the
other apps triggering your app
to launch.  We handle both of
these for navigation.
For explicit deep links we have
nav deep
link builder and its sole goal
in life is to deep link to a
specific destination in your
navigation graph by its ID.
It's easy to say but a little
bit harder to make sure that all
works in the system.
But if we create a nav deep link
builder, you create it with
context, give it your graph,
destination, any arguments you
have, and then you can
just
call create pending intent.  We
are doing all the work to create
it within your graph and your
parent activities as well.  And
we are going to pass that along
and create the correct intent
that gives you to the right
place when you trigger this
intent.  And then you just pass
it through to your notification.
You don't actually need to do
more than this to get all the
correct behavior.
For implicit deep links these
are again links to web URLs.  So
in this case instead of it being
something that you create
programatically it's information
you include in your navigation
graph.  So here we are adding a
deep link
element just like we added the
arguments and actions to our
graph, these are just a deep
link.  And of course all of this
individual editor as part of the
products for a destination.
And it's really just as simple
as an app on your URI.
This is a static URI which is
boring and dumb.
So we of course support some
wild cards.
So if you want to do a dot star
for a
wild for a wild card, totally
supported.  If you wanted to
fill in the argument
for your destination you can use
curly
braces and we will parse the URL
for you
and extract those values and
give them to you.  Now you can
get those directly from
your URL and not have to reparse
things like you already know
what this is
suppose.  Like, you already know
what this is supposed to be.
Similarly you can combine the
two.
If you want the make more
complicated patterns, you can.
We also have auto verify.  We
wanted to make sure that you can
do the same kind of thing if
you're using navigation as well.
And note here that we left off
the
HTTP, HTTPS.  Here we are doing
both.
We are saying HTTP, HTTPS.
You can't really control the
URLs that
other apps -- maybe they
accidently took the S off your
URL but we still want to support
both of those just as a
convenience method instead of
having two lines.
And of course it also works with
custom schemes.  So if you have
your own scheme, they
use set ups specifically for
your app, you can also attach
those to deep links.
Now the best part is we kind of
worked
across the tool space so besides
just the navigation editor we
also worked
with the manifest merger team.
You can add a single nav graph
element
to your activity in your
manifest pointing to your graph
and all the deep links in that
graph will then get expanded out
to be the correct intent filter.
We'll build all those for you.
And if you go to the manifest
merger
view in
in Android Studio you see the
exact line.  So this means that
we now have a single source of
truth in your
navigation graph that you know
this is
not going to get out of out of
sync with what you expect, it's
not going to get
out have sync when you change
your argument names and XML
file.  This is one central place
to do things and we think it's a
lot easier for
basically all of the implicit
deep link kind of cases.
Of course we do do things where
this is
all action view URLs as they
would be for web URLs.  You can
see it added directly to the
line.  If you have multiple of
them it will tell you what line,
if you have multiple graphs
associated with different
activities those will all work
just fine.
So one of the other subjects
that is
really important to all of our
architecture component is
testing.
Testing navigation is very hard
and this is something that we
are going to continue to look at
over the alpha period.  We
really want all of your feedback
as well.  But I wanted to
discuss what we think testing in
a navigation world should look
like.
So a lot of it is if all of the
links
between your destinations are
through
navigation, then it's a lot
easier to
test a destination in isolation.
You can test each destination by
itself and then test just the
out going
edges or the incoming arguments
and not have to deal with oh did
it actually do the right
fragment transaction?  Because
we could test that just at the
navigation controller level.  So
this is something that we are
going to spend a lot more time
on and in the fragment talk
yesterday we actually
talked about really trying to
make fragments themselves much
more testable in isolation so
it's kind of a package deal
where we are trying to build
testing into navigation
controller and
also trying to build testable
destinations as well.
So you might be interested to do
something right now.
So
if you want to test, oh when I
navigate to something, does it
go to the right place?
We actually have a ad on
navigation list inner.
You can get a call back of oh
did you
go to the right place when I
clicked this button.
This is one method we found
successful in testing things
completely black box outside of
things.
If you want to inject a nav
controller
or use any other method those
are also valid ways of kind of
setting things up.
So what can you play with today?
What can you play with -- you
must have looked at it, right?
It is in alpha right now.  1.00
alpha 01.  Giving ourselves a
long runway of bug fixes and
improvements here.
And it really comes down to two
main artifacts, the navigation
fragment which includes the
navigation
run time dependency as a
transitive dependency and also
the nav host fragment and fract
Navigator that you
need to use destinations.
And for every one of the
dependencies
for navigation, we have a dash
KTX version of them.
So we really tried to make Colin
a first class citizen,
especially if you are doing
programmatic graph construction
like say you're reading your
whole navigation graph from a
server we have
a call a call in DSL.
So there's more
to do and I'll have Lukas talk
about where we go.
>> LUKAS BERGSTROM: Are are
going to
need and troid studio preview
canary 3.14.  Please do download
it and try it out.  There's a
lot of great stuff there.  This
is obviously going to become a
really core part of not just
architecture components but
jetpack overall.
We took a blank sheet of paper,
what
do we want the and Droid
the Android developer experience
to be.  Creating a new project
in Android
Studio is going to by default
start you up in the nav editor
and it should be a pretty great
world.
And jetpack is available for you
to try right now.
It's right now it's sort of got
a much nicer introduction to
what all the key
pieces of Android development
are so
it's a much easier on ramp and
we are looking forward to
expanding this story over time.
There are more talks for you to
go to.
A lot more detail on AndroidKtx
and paging.
Paging in particular is a really
cool
deep library that does a lot for
you by tieing together different
pieces of
architecture component and
jetpack.  If you ever have a
list view with more
stuff than you can hold in
memory at any given time you
really want to go to this
pageing talk.
And we want your feedback.  We
want your feedback on this
session, first of all but more
importantly we want your
feedback on the navigation
component.  The reason that we
are launching to alpha is not
because we think that this
is sort of really untested and
untried.  We have done a lot of
prerelease testing of this.
But we are launching it to alpha
because we want to get a lot of
feedback
from the community before we
lock down on the API and switch
over the beta.
This is a great time for to you
try it out, tell us what works
for us, tell us what doesn't.
Either communicate with us
directly or on our publication
tracker.  We would love to hear
from your.  Your feedback has
been critical in every point of
this journey in making sure we
are attacking the right problems
at the right solutions so please
do try it out and tell us what
you think.
Thank you.
[Applause]
.
(Standing by).
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand Am bass doors will assist
you guiding you through the
exits.  If you've registered for
the next session in this room we
ask that you clear the room and
return via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
.
" Real time caption
Realtime captioning on this
screen" Realtime captioning on
this screen" .
.
What's now in Android security.
New in Android Security.
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
and
welcome to the Android P edition
of what is new in Android
security.  My name is Dave.  In
a few minutes I'll hand over to
Xiaowen who is the lead security
product manager for the Android
platform.  We have a lot of
ground to cover so we will start
with a brief state of the union
on Android security and jump
into all the really cool things
we have been
working on Android security over
the
past year and launching here at
Android
P including secure hardware
support, integrity and privacy.
State of the union, let's talk a
little bit about what the
Android security strategy looks
like.  There are three main
pillars.
First, Google play protect.
This is the malware and security
services.  The second is
platform engineering.
These are the corp operating
system
defenses that we built into
Android to
improve security systems such
as SE Linux, encryption, lots of
other features.
The third pillar is the security
development life cycle.  These
are all the programs we put in
place to ensure a consistent
high quality level for security
across the Android ecosystem.
Things like testing
infrastructure, also includes
our security patching programs.
We have been working really hard
on that.
A couple of things, we have been
trying
to make Android just easier to
patch.
Google, we have a pretty steady
track
record delivering those patches
to market.
And so making Android more
modular
with projects like treble really
help contribute to that.  We
also head on working security
patching into our OEM
agreements.  This will really be
a massive lead to
a massive increase in a number
of
devices and users receiving
regular security patches so we
are excited about that.
But there are a couple of
philosophical Principles that
underlie everything we do when
it comes to security.
We believe in transparency and
openness because that breeds
confidence and it breeds trust.
Conversely a closed platform,
secrecy, that breeds distrust
but there's a really important
security advantage to being
open.  Today's model devices are
faced with really sophisticated
attack threats.  When you have
billions of users it's
an attractive target so it
deserves the strongest possible
defense.
With a closed platform the
defenders
are the employees of the ones
that own the platform.
We have thousands of owners
waking up
every morning thinking of how to
best protect us, we have
security teams who
work closely with Google on
protecting
Android and its users.  We have
security teams helping to
protect Android.
We have the worldwide open
source
Linux community contributing to
Android security every day.  We
have the academic research
community which prefer working
on open platforms.
So this is a mass force
multiplier in protection.
As operating systems have
matured, the
power of open has become evident
to the point where today the
protective
capabilities of Android are now
on par with any other global
platform and I believe the power
of open will accelerate those
protective capabilities for our
users going forward.  The other
really important philosophy that
underlies our strategy is
measurability.  We always look
for objective independent
measurements to help not only
inform the work we do to insure
we are investing in the right
directions but also to measure
progress.  So one example you
see here is the incidence of
malware or potentially
harmful applications we call PHA
on devices.
The bottom curve are devices
that load
only from play, and the top
curve are devices that load from
sources other than play.  You
can see over time it has been
reducing across all users so we
are committed to protecting
users regardless of where they
get their applications from.
But this is due, this
improvement is due to many
things.
It's locking down APIs and
permissions over time or
constantly looking at that
and investing in the malware
detection engine itself.
Today 60% of malware is detected
through Machine Learning and
that's one area of a big
investment for us.
Over the past year we had a 50%
reduction of PHA on play.  We
are happy with the progress but
we are not content with where we
stand today.  Although I would
say the odds of loading a PHA
from play business the same as
being struck from lightning so
it is a safe place to live on
your mobile life while we are
going to continue to invest
tremendously in this area.
Another really important
measurement is the overall
ability of the operating system
to protect itself against
exploitation.
In any complex product there are
going to be bugs but there's no
reason why bugs have to lead to
exploitation to harm users so we
worked hard on building features
and improvements that make
Android much more difficult and
expensive to exploit.
How do you measure how well
you're doing?
Well, lots of people want to
purchase exploits.
There's a vibrant market for
that.  As exploits get more
difficult the law of supply and
demand, the prices are going to
go up.  We watch the pricing
over time and there's a number
of different markets you can
look at.
On the left side you see the
device manufacturer's rewards
programs.  Google is paying out
the highest rewards this the
industry.
Another market are the elite
hacking contests.
You can see on the graph on the
right
the price of Android has risen
to the point where now the most
recent event a few months ago
the pricing for Android is on
par with other platforms.
If you haven't seen the results,
Android performed right well in
that event.  Another market is
the great market.  Independent
researchers and brokers who will
sell exploits to the highest
bidder.  This is a little harder
to track but
we have connections to a lot of
researchers and the price of
exploitation on Android is now
as high or higher than any other
platform.
So this is really great.  We are
happy with progress but we
continue to invest in all these
areas.  Now let's switch gears
and talk about some of the new
emerging features in Android P
starting with Android protected
confirmation.
So the problem here is in
today's
secure mobility we use mobile
devices much more than we ever
did before but there's still a
ceiling of trust that we haven't
quite broken through.
We don't vote for Prime Minister
or president from our phones.
We don't program
don't program critical medical
diseases medical devices from
our phones.
I'll talk about a few use cases,
medical, financial and
enterprise but
the key innovation is protected
confirmation is the first time
that we now have the ability to
execute a high assurance
transaction, a user transaction
completely within secure
hardware, running in a trusted
execution environment or TE,
that runs separate from the main
operating system.
So how does it work?  So an
application developer, say
you're a medical company that is
developing a solution for people
with
diabetes so you're managing an
insulin pump.
The application will enable the
user to select two insulin units
and call the
protection API to transmit that
data to the secure hardware area
where a completely independent
trusted user interface will
execute.  The interface you see
here on the
screen shows the two insulin
units, the
user confirms it by pressing a
button.  It's guarded in this
area.  And the entire
transaction is signed using a
transcriptd key that never
leaves that security area.
This provides higher assurance
to the relying party that the
integrity of this data was not
corrupted even if you had
root level malware it cannot
corrupt the integrity of that
transaction.
So in code this is really easy.
We use the standard Android key
store API.
We have this new method to set a
flag confirmation required.
We create the confirmation
dialogue
using the confirmation dialogue
API and
use the method to transfer
control where the user will
interact with that special
screen.  Really easy.
So we have a number of launch
partner
whose have been working closely
with us on this technology.
They have been building
prototypes.
Big foot medical is a program
that works on solutions for
people with diabetes.
The user is looking at the
glucose
level deciding I want to inject
one and a half insulin units and
calls the API
to invoke the interface.
The user confirms and only then
will the insulin pump administer
that dose.
In the medical side we have
royal bank Canada that is
working to integrate protected
confirmations into their
application.  I don't have a
video for this one but you can
track left the right this
application is moving a person
to person financial transfer.
We see we are going to send
$1,500 to ravy.
The application invokes the
protected confirmation's API.
The user confirms 1500.  1500
can't be changed to 15,000.
The relying party on the other
end has
high confidence that we intended
to send
ravy $1,500 and the transaction
goes through.
Duo security is a firm that is
working on strong enterprise
authentication.
Imagine you're logging into your
Chromebook and it launchs a
second factor authentication to
your phone.
The duo security's application
comes up and asks for
confirmation but then there's a
second level confirmation using
the protected confirmation API
that provides again higher level
of assurance for the enterprise
that it is the device and user
and location that is expected
for that authentication.
So there are a lot of other
launch partners we worked
closely with on this.
on this.
Proks to me is doing proximal
based authentication.
I would like to throw a shout
out
to qual com.
Protected confirmation requires
a deep
integration at the hardware
level, it's optional for P so it
requires a supported Android P
device.  We are breaking through
that last
ceiling of assurance in mobility
so it's very exciting.
There's a lot more to talk
about.  I would like to call up
Xiaowen to take us through this
story.  (Applause).
>> XIAOWEN XIN: Thanks, Dave.
Good morning, everyone.  And I'm
really excited to be here to
talk about a lot more of the
security
and privacy features that we
built into Android P.
As Dave mentioned security
hardware is a huge focus area
for us because it can provide
defenses against attacks that
software alone is not sufficient
to
handle.  Another API, another
feature that we
are making in Android P is
leveraging secure hardware also.
So why do we need stronger
protection?  Google pay is a
great example here.  We are
working closely with them on
this P feature and they're going
to launch with it later this
year.  Consider their security
goal n the
traditional transit use case
they need to make sure that your
transit card and only your card
can be used to pay for your bus
ride so your transit card has
your account information, a lot
of secrets in there that
represents your account.
Now the transit card is made
using a
security element inside of it so
it's
hard to break into it and
extract secrets.
Android pay transit is working
to replace that card with your
phone.  We need to make sure we
provide the same security
guarantees which that is your
secrets cannot be extracted out
of your phone and put to another
phone.  To pay for your bus ride
you must present your phone.
A great solution here is use
secure hardware.
Now Google pay transit is one
example.  Payments is another.
In all of these use cases you
want to make sure that your
phone and only your phone can
make that transaction.  There
are quite a few other examples
where we benefit from stronger
protect from private keys.
For example, if you have high
value
Cloud data, if you're an
enterprise or financial
institution you want to make
sure that all requests, all data
access is coming from a known
phone or phone that you trust
and that phone is identified by
a private key.
Also if you have high value
local data, let's say your
password manage,
you're storing passwords locally
on disk
then you may want to protect it
again with a private key.
How do we provide stronger
protection for private keys?
There are exacting standards
certifyd by professional labs to
be resistant to hardware
tampering.  Phones are starting
to incorporate that exact
hardware directly into the
phone so your phone can replace
your transit card or credit
card.
With Android P we are now
exposing APIs so all
applications on Android can take
advantage of this tamper
resistant
hardware on compatible devices.
Specifically we are adding a new
type of key store called
strongbox.
Strongbox is built using tamper
resistant hardware security
elements
that has isolated CPU, RAM and
secure storage.  It makes it so
that it's resistant to shared
resource attacks.  For example,
many of the high profile
hardware attacks we heard about
recently, strongbox is resistant
to
those as well as timing attacks
as well as physical attacks.
So when we look at the key store
types that are available on
Android there are
now three types of key store.
On older Android devices key
store was implemented using it
directly.
Even when now devices it was
using the TE, trusted execution
environment.
Now we are providing strongbox
that can run alongside together
with the existing key store and
the TE.
Strongbox is resistant to the
widest variety of attacks and
well suitd if you
have a use case that requires
strong
protection for your private
keys.  It does require new
hardware.
To use strongbox it's fairly
straightforward.
When you create your key store
key set a new flag.
If a device supports strongbox
then
everything succeeds and it goes
well.
If not, you will get an
unavailable exception.
It uses tamper resistant
hardware and
this is the first time that we
are offering a generic API to
access the type of secure
hardware for key management.
This feature as well as the
protected confirmation API are
really pushing the boundary for
security hardware support on
mobile and we are really excited
about the use cases that this
enable also.
So protecting your private key
is one thing that apps need to
do.
Another is to make sure that the
right user is present.
When you look at a typical
Android
device the most likely security
incident
to happen to that device is not
malware but rather getting lost
or stolen so a locked screen is
very important for Android, make
sure you set a lock screen.  And
also an app developer make sure
you gain sensitive access on
user authentication.
So in Android P we added a few
different features to help ad
developers do that
starting with key guard bound
keys.  Key guard bound keys are
key store
keys that are well suited for
protecting
data that you store on the
device.
Key guard bound keys have their
functionality tied to the key
guard so the keys can be used to
encrypt data at any time and
decrypt data only when the
device is unlocked.
The life cycle of the keys are
tied to the life cycle of the
lock screen.  If you have very
sensitive confidential
enterprise data or private
health and fitness data you
might want
to encrypt it with a key guard
bound key before you store to
disk.  It's now a little bit
harder for an attacker to access
the sensitive data.
To use a key guard bound key
it's also fairly straightforward
when you create your key store
key set a flag to require
that the squeeze the device be
unlocked.
When you create your object you
can
create it for encryption
at any time and for decryption
when the device is unlocked.
What if your device had been
properly
unlocked but you want the check
user authentication one for time
let's say before a sensitive
action like a payment happens.
This is where a biometric prompt
comes in.
It's our replacement
for fingerprint manage.
Fingerprint manage has a few
limitations.
One is it only works for
fingerprint.
A lot of devices today are
starting to
support face, iris and other
modalities.  We do support more
than just fingerprint.  And it
will automatically pick the
right modality for that user for
that device.
Another benefit of biometric
prompt is it uses standard
system UI which is really nice
when user experience
perspective to show the user
standard UI when they're making
security relevant decisions.
Also it sets us up well for
future advances in sensor
technology when you
have an indisplay fingerprint
sensor, it
tells you where to put your
finger.
We know that biometric prompt is
quite
different from fingerprint
manager and
so to ease the main of migration
we are also providing a support
library and so apps will be able
to call one API in
that support library and that
will use
biometric
prompt.
To use biometric prompts, create
the
further object and pass the
title and
subtitle of properties then call
the
authentic to show
the authentication prompt.
We ask you use the crypto object
to user
to user authorization is proper.
Now, what if the user is going
to your website in Chrome?
How do you authenticate them
there
?  Coming later this year in Q
four
Chrome on Android will support
web op N which means if the user
is going to your
website they can use their log
screen or
biometric signals to
authenticate to your use site.
If you like to buy things on the
web
pay pal has a demo running where
you can
use your fingerprint to
authenticate to PayPal and to
make your purchase.
It's more
convenient than typing in your
password every time you make a
purchase.  To summarize several
different methods we talked
about to gain access based on
authentication, first with key
guard
bound keys you can tie data
access to the life cycle of the
lock screen.
If the user already unlocked the
screen you can use biometric
prompt to show system UI.  And
if the user is going to your
website instead of your native
app you
can use web
web auth.  Now that you
determined it's the right user,
let's talk about integrity.
A lot of apps need to make sure
that
the integrity of the data and
the integrity of the device
they're running on.
In Android P to help you protect
the integrity of your data in
transit we are
going to require TLS by default.
If the system will throw an
exception
if the app sends data in the
clear.
Using TLS should be a no-brainer
because it protects the privacy
of your users and protects your
content from
being modified in transit,
whether it's
unwanted adds or tracking
identifiers or
to exploit a weakness in your
app.
You should always incrept.
You can still opt out in
specific domains by updating
your network security configure.
Do visit the website on the
slide.  Now before you run off
to change your code we have one
more piece of good news.
For a lot of apps care about
cryptographic compliance because
it's important in regulated
industries tan government.
So we are really happy that what
is used to security SSL traffic
on Android.
Recently we received
CAVP certificates for many
approved
algorithms so this means
that developers
s have automatic fips
compliance.
Another topic in the integrity
section is how do I make sure
that the device has not been
tampered with?
The device itself is still
healthy?
In Android O we introduced key
attestation which allows you to
get a
signed statement from the secure
hardware itself about the state
of the
device and about the property of
your private keys.  It can tell
you whether the device passed
verified boot, whether it's
running a recent security patch,
whether your private keys are
protected by TE or strongbox.
Another thing that key
attestation
will return to you is the firm
wear hash
that the device is running.
Think of this as transparency
enabled verified.  What this
means if you're running a
firm way test that is the same
as a
known good version you are
running a bit for bit version so
that's a
powerful thing to know about
when you're running.  To know
that operating system you're
running is an exact good copy of
a known version.
To users of the safety net
attestation API, it will call
the platform under the hood.  So
you will be able to take
advantage of this without any
changes to your code.
Now in some cases if you want to
get more information from the
API than what
is returned by safety you can
still call directly.
Now last but certainly not
least, privacy.  Privacy is an
important area to security.  We
actually talked about privacy
quite
a bit already when we talked
about the
TLS by default feature coming in
Android.  But there are a few
other privacy
features that are in Android P
that we want to cover now.
First this is probably one of my
favorite features.
Sensor access only in the
foreground.
In Android P running on an
Android P
device regardless of your API
level if
your app is in the background
and idle you will no longer be
able to access the
camera, microphone or sensors.
This behavior is slightly
different based on the exact
characteristics of the API
you're targeting.  With the
microphone API you will get
silence when you try to access
microphone from the background
in idle.
With a camera API it will behave
as if
you were preempted by a higher
priority camera clients.
With the sensors it's whether
it's continuously or via call
back.
If the app is in the background
you can no longer access data
from sensors.
If you need to access the camera
, microphone or sensors create a
foreground service with a
persistent user notification.
That gives users more control
and transparency into which apps
have access to their sensors at
that time.
To start a foreground service
create
that notification first and
start thetory ground method and
pass it to that notification.
All right.
Besides background access to
sensors, restricted background
access to sensors we added a lot
more control over your data.
Android is the first major
operatingtism to have DNS over
TLS support built right in.
Your queries will be passed to a
source of your choice.
Now if your default DNS already
supports we will automatically
encrypt your data.
We did this in collaboration
with alphabet jigsaw team.  We
are looking forward to many new
developments here.
Another cool feature we added in
Android
P in the privacy space is lock
down mode.  It's useful if
you're in a situation
where you may temporarily lose
access to your device.
Let's say you need to hand it
over in a security check point.
You can put it in lock down mode
which is in a state where all
your knowledge factors can be
used to lock down the device.
Your fingerprint biometrics will
be disabled.
Notifications will no longer
show on the lock screen.  You
have higher assurances on the
security of the lock screen when
the
device is temporarily out of
sight.
So that was a quick overview of
the features that are coming
with Android P.  There's a lot
more that we didn't have time to
cover.
So please do give us your
feedback
and send us an e-mail.
Thank you for coming and have a
great day.
(Applause)
.
"Realtime
captioning on this screen" .
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
you
getting you through the exists.
If you registered for the next
session, we ask that you clear
the room
and return via the registration
line outside.  Thank you.
in this room, we ask that you
clear the room and return via
the registration line outside.
Thank you.
.
Personalize actions for the
Google
Assistant
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
.
>> Hello.
Welcome to personalize actions
for the Google Assistant.
Thanks for being here.  I'm
Silvano Luciani.
I work in the assistance and
actions on Google developer
relations team.
>> ADAM DAWES: My name is Adam
Dawes.
We build identity tools for
developers.
>> SILVANO LUCIANI: In the next
half hour we are going to
provide to you some
of the functionality that Google
provides to you.  Why is it
important to personalize your
action?
And let's start by looking at
the Google Assistant.
This is the assistive technology
that
is at the center of an ecosystem
of more
than 500 -- sorry, million
devices.  And it's there to help
users to get things done.
Things like listening to music
or
playing some games, get informed
by watching some news, learn new
recipes and so on.
Actions in Google is the
platform that allows you to
extend the Assistant.  You can
add your on actions so you can
provide help for a knowledge
domain where you think you are
an expert and you can provide
value to the user.
You can connect with new users
across
all the devices that we have
seen and you can innovate by
adding conversational interface
that can make some of the tasks
very easy, just a straight voice
command.
So thinking about this there are
two aspects where it's important
to personalize your action.
Aspect number one is for some of
the things you might want to do
like for example present music
that a user can listen to to be
entertained, if you know
more about the preference and
the tastes you can provide them
with music that will be more in
line with their
expectation and fulfill their
intent in a better way.  We have
seen your actions can be
involved across different
devices so you
want to be able if the user
expressed preferences for
example as a speaker, honor
those preferences when they
start
another conversation with on a
different device like a
smartphone will you will be able
to provide a better experience
because now you can show visuals
to provide a better output to
the user.
So we are going to look at three
main
packets thats that already was
mentioned.  The first one is
what is the platform providing
to us so that we can learn
something more about the
Assistant user.  Then we see how
we can store this information in
the current conversation we have
with the user or all the
conversation we might have with
the user which means future
conversation and conversation on
different devices.
Finally Adam will talk about
adding identity to your action.
That can be a requirement where
cases for example where the user
wants to know where the next
payment for a certain service is
due, if you are the service
provider you need to know who
they are
on your system, you need to
authenticate them so you can
receive the correct information
for their account.
So starting from learning more
about the
Assistant users I'm going to
introduce helper intents.
Helper intents are a core
concept of the Assistant
platform.
You can request
to the Assistant conversation so
it can
perform special tasks on your
behalf.
Some of the special tasks, you
can ask to transfer the
conversation if you start the
conversation on a smart speaker
you want to show a visual to the
user, you can ask the
conversation to be transferred
to a phone or added device
that can show the visual or you
can even deep link into an
Android app if for
example the user has
has requested a task that
doesn't provide a good user
experience with a voice
interface.
In this talk we are going to
look at a
subset of the helpers that allow
you to obtain information from
the user.  This information can
be two different types.
One is you can ask to the user
the consent for the assistant to
share some information with your
action like the user name or the
device location.  The location
of the device where the
conversation is happening.
Date and time and place and
location are a way of asking an
input to the user.
I need a date for you, if, for
example, your actions allow
users to
book services and you want to
know when they want the service
or a place or location if you
are arranging a delivery and you
want to know where the deliver
the transaction.  So starting
from the first one, how can we
get the user name?
In this slide what you see on
your left is a simulation of a
conversation I
did on a test app that I wrote
and on the right you can see
some of the code from our node.
js client library.  It's not the
complete code from the
action, it's just what is
relevant to what I'm showing.
And you can see how it works.
First ask the permission, the
permission to get the name of
the user.  And you provide the
context, that it's very
important.  Because with the
context you are explaining to
the user why you need the
name, how is your service going
to be better if you obtain that
information.  So in this case
I'm telling them hey I
want to address you by your
name.
In the Assistant they cover the
conversation, ask the user can I
share this information?
If it's a positive rely you get
access
and you can use it to greet the
user by the name.  If not, you
need to deal with it.  A
knowledge that they didn't want
to share the information with
you, try to provide the best
service that you can.
This next slide is showing to
you the row JSON API.  If you're
not using the client library and
instead you're using the
conversation webhook, this is
how you question the permission.
You can see the intent name is
action
intent of permission and then
there's a pack of parameters
that can go.
They are different for every
helper intent.
And they are
defined saying this request
might contain this type of
field.  And you can see the
context explain using I want
that information.
This is showing you in the
following request that you
received from the Assistant if
the user consented to give you
access to the information, this
is how you receive it.
Location is very similar because
it's exactly the same intent,
it's an intent that is called
permission.
And
again the aft is asking the user
can I share the location of your
device with the action?  If the
user replies yes, you get access
to the location and now in this
case you could resolve the
latitude and longitude to the
place where they are and then
try something that it's near
that location.
JSON is pretty similar, it's
just only like a different value
for the type of permission that
we are asking.  And one thing
that you can notice now
is permission is an array which
means if you want to ask for
both the name and location at
the same time, you can do it.
You can just ask for multiple
permissions in that array.
This is how you get the location
if the
user consents to give it to you.
Now date, time is different.  In
this case we are not anymore
asking
the user if the Assistant can
share some information with our
action.
We are directly asking the user
can you give me a date, a date
value?
And the most powerful thing when
you
do this through the Assistant is
we can resolve ways of
specifying the date that are not
just the date format.  So if you
look at the example, when would
you like to reserve the table?
I reply tomorrow.
The Assistant says what tomorrow
is to the time we are having the
conversation.
Another thing you might notice
in this case we have three
prongs, an initial
prong that is the reason why we
want to ask that information but
there's also a
date and time additional prong
that the
Assistant uses if it gets only
parts of the information that
you need from the user.
So if I only specify a date like
in the case of the example where
I just said tomorrow, the
Assistant will ask
what time using the prompt that
you specify.  Once you have that
information you can
access it in the case of node.js
client library.
Again, not very different.  Thp
is the JSON.
So what is changing is just
the parameters you are passing
when you
are asked for this helper and
the value you get.  It's a
little longer because you have
the date part and the time part.
The last helper is the place and
location helper.
Again, this is not anymore
asking the user can I share your
current location with the
action.
It's asking the user give me a
place, give me a location.
Again, you can see that if you
use
this helper we can resolve
things like the public name of a
place.  For example, when the
action asks where would you like
to pick it up?
And I reply Shoreline am
theatre, what
you get is the whole address.
Not a lot of difference again.
You already know this API.
It's all -- it's a very familiar
API by now.  The only things
that are changing are the type
of parameters you can send along
with helper and the name of the
helper itself.
And the request in this case you
got a little more info because
you have the address, the public
name and some more stuff.
Why is it not going?  Okay.
In this example where you have
side to side two different
situations.  The first one is
the place.  We have seen how we
can resolve a
public place, you ask
for a Shoreline Amphitheater,
you get the address.  But it's
showing a location.  A location
is something that a user defines
and it's private to them.  For
example my home or my workplace.
And so in the example on the
right
when I ask work, the Assistant
requests
again another type of consent
which is can I share with the
action what work is for you?
And only if the user says yes,
then
you can get that address.
If you want to see more about
helpers we
have a sample, GitHub dot
com/actions-on Google.  It shows
all the helpers that are
available on the platform.
There's information that can be
useful that we can find in every
request without the need of
requesting any specific helper.
The first one is just there and
it's called last seen.  It's
just the time stamp of the last
interaction with the user.  The
first time the user has an
interaction with the action it
will be undefined.  After that
you will always have the time
stamp of the last interaction.
This means you can use it, for
example, to greet them
differently.  You can just say
welcome the first
time and then if the time stamp
is is available, you can say
welcome.
You can do more complex stuff.
You can calculate how much time
passed since the last time they
visited you and depending on
whether you consider that
range to be short or long time
you can reengage with them in a
different way.
The other one that is
interesting for
all of you that have Android
apps that
allow users to purchase or
subscribe to entitlements, you
can connect your
action to an Android app, it's
just in the verification that
you actually own the Android
app.
And all the entitlements that
that
user bought on the Android app
and Play will be available in
every request.  This is an
example of how you would see it.
In this case I'm just giving you
an JSON
example because in the client
library we
built the JavaScript object that
contains this information.  What
about storing information in the
conversation?
We said that it's important that
we can do it so we can give a
more personalized experience
inside a conversation but also
across all the different
conversations that the user can
have with your action.
The first concept that I like to
introduce to you is the
conversation token.  The
conversation token, it's
available only if you're using
an action SDK action.
And it's a field of the response
and
the request defined in the
conversation webhook API.
It's just a screen like if you
write
to it we will send back what
you've written in the next
request.  If you change it we
will do it again.
The main catch is it's value is
always initialized to an empty
screen.  It's always the current
conversation
and all the values you stored in
there will be cleared when the
conversation ends.  You can use
it for improvements when those
improvements make sense only in
the like cycle of the current
conversation that you're having.
One example of how to write the
value, in the first case I'm
just writing a simple string.
In the second case what I'm
doing
because I want to use a more
structure approach I'm
serializeing the JSON object to
a screen so I can get a
representation that contains an
object.
Dialogue flow you don't have
access to
the conversation token but the
same
functionality with a more
powerful abstraction called
output context.  You can have
more than one output context.
Each one has a name and you can
identify the name, you can set
the lifespan in terms of
conversation for which that data
will be available and it
provides an interface that gives
you access the a structured
value.
To see an example of an output
context
you can see an output context at
an array, it's identified by a
very long time.
The lifetime count is five turns
in
this case and I'm writing an
object for
what are the value that I want
to store in this context.
To use the client library and
node.
js we give you the best of both
worlds.  We provide you an
obstruction, you write whatever
you want to the object.  And
depending on whether your action
is an action SDK or dialogue
flow we use the conversation
token in one case or the output
context in the other.
To see an example of how you
could use it, let's say you have
some music that you want to
play.
The user asks I want to listen
to some music.  You can ask them
do you want a random genre?  A
specific genre?  If they give
you one, you can save it for the
rest of the conversation.  You
can keep giving them music
coming from that genre.
And you can also have a counter
where you count how many songs
for that genre you've been given
to the user and when
they reach a certain point let's
say ten songs you ask do you
still want this genre or do you
want to change?
In some other cases the
conversation token doesn't work
because let's say you want to
store the preferences for an
action that is giving you
weather
forecast and you want to save
the zip or
area code to identify the area
for where they want the
forecast.
If you save this in a
conversation token that value is
lost at the next conversation.
So you would be asking again
what is your zip?  And that's
not a good experience.
And that's when user storage
comes into play.
This slide is exactly the same
API of conversation token so you
already know how to use this.
It's a field of response
request, it's
a string, you can write just a
string or
serialize a structured data.  We
will recirculate it across all
the conversation that you're
having with the user.  Future
conversation, conversation on
different devices.
The main difference is the
content can
be clear only by the app itself
or by the usered only by the app
itself or by the user.  And we
will see it in a couple of
slides.
So this is exactly the same
example that I had for the
conversation token.  The only
thing that has changed is the
name of the field.  Now I'm
using user storage and that
means I have access to a bigger
lifespan.
Going back to the example of
storing, now that we store it in
the user
storage, if I started this
conversation on a smart speaker,
save the zip, the moment I asked
for the forecast from my
phone the action will know the
zip code and won't need to ask
for it again.
That's it.
This is how you clear the value.
If you're using the client
library you set the value of the
storage to an empty object and
we clear it for you.  Last thing
I have to say about the user
storage is very important.  This
is mostly like a cookie and so
there are some countries that
have
strong regulations about
obtaining consent from the user
before you can save or read data
from the user storage.  So if
you operate in one of these
countries, make sure that you
use the
helper that is a helper that
allows you to ask something to
the user and get a
yes or no question
no request before you start
writing from the user storage.
Now it's time for Adam to talk
about identity.  (Applause).
>> ADAM DAWES: Thank you
Silvano.
User storage is a terrific
feature to hold state and build
continuity with the user across
multiple conversations.
It works a lot like a cookie or
HTML5 might in a browser but we
know that isn't always enough so
let me talk a little bit about
how you can use identity to
further deepen your experience
with the user.
So the first thing that you get
with identity is you get to know
who the user is.
You get to know her name, her
e-mail address and you get
access to her profile picture.
This allows you to build a
direct relationship with the
user where you can
engage her via e-mail outside of
the context of using your app.
The next thing that identity
provides is
the ability to have a consistent
experience across multiple
devices and on different
platforms.  So with user storage
you're able to keep applications
state and user preferences but
all that data is stored
in Google's Cloud and only
available to your conversational
action.
But with identity, now you can
store all of the user's data on
your own back end.
And whether or not the user
comes back via your mobile app,
the web or your conversational
action, you'll be able to re-set
the state for the user and get
her going where she left off the
last time she used your service.
Finally with identity now that
you have all her data stored on
your back end identity can now
help you secure that data so
only the user has access to it
and nobody else does.
So the actions on Google
platform has supported identity
from the very beginning with
OAuth based account linking but
the problem that we found is
that when a user engages with
your action via voice, the only
way to be able to do that
account linking
experience was to punt the user
to the phone and get the user to
go to your website, log in and
complete the linking experience.
These kinds of cross device
flows are
super difficult and as you can
imagine
the conversion rate is pretty
low.  That's why we are super
excited to
announce the developerer preview
for the Google sign in for
Assistant.
You sign into your app
completely via
voice without needing to leave
the context of the conversation.
And like Google sine in on other
platforms woor are able to
automatically log users in if
they previously used your
service on a different device or
another platformSign in on other
platforms woor are able to
automatically log users in if
they previously used your
service on a different device or
another platform.
It comes in two different
developer modes.
In multi platform this provides
a seem
less voice base experience for
Google
user yet still maintains a path
for users that registered with
your service with another
identity.  For Assistant only
developers we are
especially excited about what
Google sign in for a Assistant
is going to be able to do.  We
heard you that identity and
account linking is a heavy lift
just to get
started on the platform.
Now for Google sign in for
Assistant you're able to rely
completely on Google
to manage identity.
Let's take a look at how one of
these
Assistant only developers
planning on using the tool.
Starbutter AI was founded by
four self-described personal
finance geeks
who love to argue with each
other about the best way to
manage their personal
finances and look for financial
services products.  They all
found themselves with a similar
experience where they're friends
and families would
would inundate them with
questions about the best credit
cards or how to get a mortgage.
They realized the best way to
recommend financial services
products was to get to know the
user you there a question and
answer dialogue.
They are invested so big into AI
and building on the Assistant
platform.
Just last year they won an award
for being one of the top actions
ton Assistant platform.
But to offer advice that will
keep users coming back again and
again,
Starbutter really needs a user's
identity.
Last week we gave them access to
Google Sign in for the Assistant
so
let's look at their demo app.
on the Assistant platform.  But
to offer advice that will keep
users coming back again and
again, Starbutter really needs a
user's identity.  Last week we
gave them access to Google Sign
in for the Assistant so let's
look at their demo app.
.
>> Talk to mortgage helper
demo>> Talk to mortgage helper
demo.
>> All right. Getting the test
version of mortgage helper demo.
>> Hi, I'm Morgan.
I analyze millions of data
points to find you the best
mortgage.  Want to compare loan
offers or
calculate how much you can
borrow?
>> Calculate how much I can
borrow.
>> To compare home loan offers
I'll need
your basic intoe to create a new
mortgage helper demo account.
If you want more details say
tell me more.  Can I have your
name, e-mail address and pro
tile picture from Google?
>> ADAM DAWES: Yes.
>> Great, Alix I've created a
new mortgage helper demo account
using your Google a couldn't.
Are you purchasing a property or
refinancing a property you
already own?
>> ADAM DAWES: Wasn't that so
much better.
The user was able to create an
account without leaving the
context of their conversation.
Let's look behind the scenes at
what I guess what is going on.
Google Sign in for the Assistant
operates like all others other
the platform.
You went to get to get
information
about who the user is.
If the user says yes then we
generate an ID token and hand it
back to your client.
Now let's take a look at one of
these ID tokens.
An ID token is adjustment a JSON
web token and that's basically a
dictionary
of JSON which is
cryptographiccly signed by
Google so you can be sure that
the information inside the token
is authentic.  Inside the token
you'll see all of the
information that you need in
order to be
able to make a decision about
whether the link the account or
create a new account for the
user.
That includes the user's name,
profile
picture and e-mail e-mail
address.  You'll also notice at
the top of the
screen there's the AUD field,
short for audience.  This is
also a super important field
because that pretexts the
security of the user's data.
It's what prevents another app
from
getting an ID token for that
Google user
and replaying that token against
your backend to get access to
that user's data.
Let's look at what Starbutter
had to do to get this set up.
The first thing they needed to
do was go to the actions on
Google developer console and go
to the identity and account
linking section.  There they can
figure that they used Google
Sign in as their linking type.
Next they need to update their
action.  So first they need to
initialize their client ID, this
is what comes back in the
audience and protects the user's
data.  And then they need to
find the right time to be able
to ask the user to log in and
provide consent to give their
account information.
Now Starbutter did that
relatively early and you're
going to want to be thoughtful
about why you do this.  It's not
best practice to immediately ask
the user to sign in when they
open your action so think about
that carefully.
The last thing that Starbutter
needed
to do was to handle the
resolution.
The user can agree to provide
their profile information or
they can decide not to.
If they agree, then we will be
able to return that whole set of
JSON that comes
back in the ID token and then
you'll be able to extract the
user's e-mail
address or their Google
identifier and
you can start keying data on
your
backend based on that user's
identity.  If the user decides
not to provide
that information you're going to
want to handle that gracefully.
You want to explain the benefit
of logging in.
If they still don't want to
share their information, you
will try to
forward the conversation to be
useful to
the user to the user even if you
don't know who they are.
The multi-platform developer
wants to be able to support two
types of users
both the Google user as well as
any user who may have registered
with their
service given another identify
provider like Microsoft or out
look.  They need to have that
path to able to connect to data
for both user types.
I understand it may feel like a
little bit of a caveat that only
Google users are able to get
that voice based account linking
experience but it's still going
to be Sumer impactful for your
super impactful for your action.
We know you invested a lot of
time and energy so we want to
make sure that we bring as many
users through that front door.
So by having Google users get in
streamlined voice experience,
that's going to bring many more
users to enjoy
all the benefits that your
action provides.
So let's take another look at an
action that is on multiple
platform also.
This is Itcher.
Their goal in life is to answer
that
age old question what movie or
TV show should I watch tonight?
They built a personalized
recommendation available on iOS,
Android, web and the Assistant
platform
and they offered many ways to
sign in, Google, face, even
Twitter.
Itcher needs a user's identity.
They can't store user as likes,
dislikes, and make
recommendations without having a
consistent experience across
time and across across devices.
Here is their demo app.
>> Talk to Itcher.
>> Okay.
Let's get the test version of
Itcher.
>> To get started I need your
basic info to personalize your
experience.  If you want more
detail, say tell me more.  Can I
have your name, e-mail address,
and profile picture from Google?
>> Yes.
>> Great. So now I can check to
see if you have an account with
us.  Just a sek.  I found your
account, al liks.
Your account is now linked to
Google.
>> Hi, this is Itcher. I can
give
you movies, TV shows.  How can I
help?
>> ADAM DAWES: That was a much,
much better experience.  We were
able to detect whether or not
al liks had an account with
Itcher and
seamlessly makeAlix had an
account with Itcher and
seamlessly make the experience.
How does Itcher make that
experience
with Google Sign in for
Assistant?
They need
to go to the Google developer
console.
Next they do exactly like
Starbutter, find the right time
in the conversation to ask the
user to sign in.  And then this
is where things get a little bit
different.
So in that interaction we went
and we went to do a discovery to
whether or not that account
already exists.
In order to make that happen,
Starbutter and the food both app
created a separate rest API from
their conversational action
fulfillment end point.
So we called this end point the
token
end point and it allows us to do
account discovery and creation.
So the way the logic of this end
point works is pretty
straightforward.  We ask the
user whether or not they want to
sign in to the app.
If they say yes then we generate
ID token and send to it the
token end point.
Food both validates the ID token
and extract the user's e-mail
address and do
a look up on their account
database.
If they find that user already
exists they link the account by
taking the
Google identifier and storing
that for
the user and also generate their
own own credential and return it
to Google.
Google will store that
credential and
return it in every conversation
back to the food bot app.
If in that look up on whether or
not that user already exists,
that user
doesn't exist, then food bot
will return an error saying I
never heard of that user.
So then what Google does is we
look up
food bot settings and see if
they want to support account
creation via voice.  Not all
apps want to do that.  Sometimes
the registration process
requires that they gather more
information than just the name
and e-mail address or maybe they
want to make sure that the user
is really evaluated their
privacy policy and terms of
service.
But if they do decide they want
to do voice based account
creation then we will ask the
user do you want to create an
account with food bot?  If the
user says yes, we will then
again hit the token end point
and the
token end points will again
validate the request is coming
from Google and extract the
name, e-mail address and profile
picture and store that
information as a new user in
their user database and they
will also create a
token and return that to Google
to store and then respond with
every turn of conversation to
keep that context.
Now if food bot decides they
don't want to do voice based
account creation or the user
decides they don't want to
create new account, they want to
log
into their existing account that
might
be based on Yahoo or Microsoft
identity,
then we fall back
to the regular O aupt base add
based
account flowth based account
flow.  This ensures all Google
users have this streamlined
experience.
So that's pretty much it.
It's really easy the take
advantage of
of Google Sign in for the
Assistant.
The developer preview is
available today.
Go and check out the actions on
Google developer docs and look
for the identity section.
Now as a recap, Silvano talked
to you
about how you can build a more
personalized experience with the
user by using helper intents to
get permission to get the user's
name, location, and time.
He also talked about how to use
the request info to see when the
user last used your action and
whether or not the
user is already purchased info
from your service via the play
store.  Next he talked about how
to store
information and build build
continuity with the user.
And then I led you through how
you can
use Google Sign in
for Assistant.
And for actions only developers,
now they don't even need to have
their own account system.
So we know your time is very
available.  We would love to
hear what you thought of our
presentation.
So please navigate back to the
I/O schedule, find this session
and give us a rating.
And if you want more
information, please
go online, we have t
we have got helpful docs that
describe Silvano's experiences
and best practices
and you can learn more about
Google Sign in for Assistant.
We will also be across the way
at the
Assistant code lab and
igloo tent so please come and
ask us questions.
(Applause)
.
"Realtime captioning on this
screen" .
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
you with moving to the next
session.  If you registered for
a session in this room, we ask
that you clear the
room and return through the line
outside.  Thank you.
Intro to Machine Learning on
Google Cloud platform.
Platform.
.
Intro to Machine Learning on
Google Cloud platform.
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with directing you through the
designated exists.  We will be
making room for those who
registered for the next session.
If you registered for the next
session
in this room, we ask that you
clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
.
Intro to Machine Learning on
Google Cloud platform.
Platform.
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
.
Intro to Machine Learning on
Google Cloud platform.
Platform.
.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
>> SARA ROBINSON: Hello.
Everyone.
Welcome to intro to Machine
Learning on Google Cloud
platform.  I'm Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate and I
focus on Machine Learning.
You can find me on Twitter at S
Rob tweets.  Machine Learning
involves teaching
computers to recognize patterns
in the same ways that our brains
do.
It's hard to distinguish between
a cat and dog but much more
difficult for a machine to do
the same thing.  I'm going to
focus on supervised learning.
This is when during training you
give your model labeled input.
The amount that we know about
how our
model works is going to depend
on the tool we choose to use for
the job and the type of Machine
Learning problem we are trying
to solve.  So that was a high
level overview but
how do we get from input to
description?  Again this is
going to depend on the type of
Machine Learning problem we are
trying to solve.
So in the left side saying
you're solving a generic task
that someone already solved
before.  You don't need to start
from scratch.
Let's say you're solving a
custom task
specific to your data set.
More specifically let's think of
this
in terms of image
classification.
Let's say you want to label this
picture as a cat.
We can use one of these
pretrained models.  We don't
need to start from scratch.
Let's say this cat's name is
Chloe,
this is our cat, and we want to
identify her across our entire
image library.
We need to train a model using
our own data from scratch so it
can differentiate Chloe from
other cats.
Let's say we want our model to
return a bounding box showing
where she is in that picture.
We need to train a model on our
own data.
Let's also think about this in
terms of a natural language
processing problem.
So let's say we have this text
from
one of my tweets and I want to
extract parts of speech from
that text.  This is a common
natural language processing task
so I don't need to start from
scratch.
I can utilize an exampleing
model.  Let's say I want to take
the same tweet and I want my
model to know this is a tweet
about programming and more
specifically it's a tweet about
Google Cloud.
I'm going to need to train my
model on thoughts of tweets so
they can generate
these predictions.  Many people
see the term Machine Learning
and are scared off.  They think
it's something only for experts.
If you look back about 60 years
ago this is definitely the case.
This is a picture of the first
neural
network invented in 1957 and
this was a device that
demonstrated an ability to
identify different shapes.  Back
then if you wanted to work on
Machine Learning, you needed
access to extensive academic and
computing resources.  If we fast
forward to today we can see in
the last 5 or 10 years the
number of
products of Google using Machine
Learning has grown dramatically.
At Google we want to put Machine
Learning into the hands of any
developer and data scientist
with a computer and Machine
Learning problem they want to
solve and that's all of you.
We don't Machine Learning should
be something for only experts.
Make you're using a framework
like
Scikit learn, maybe writing your
code in
Jupiter notebooks, maybe you're
experimenting with different
models,ing proofs of concept or
scaling for production?
What I want you to take away is
no matter what your existing
Machine Learning toolkit is, we
have something for you on Google
cloud plat form.
We have a whole speck room of
Machine Learning products.
On the left we have products
targeted toward application
developers.  You need little to
know Machine Learning
experience.
On the right we have products
targeted
more towards data scientists and
Machine Learning practitioners.
First APIs that give you access
to
pretrained models with a single
rest API request.  As we move
through the middle we have a new
product which I'm super excited
about that we announced earlier
this year in January called
AutoML.
The first is Auto ML vision.
Without requiring you to write
any of the model code.  As we
move further to the right
towards more custom models you
want to
build your model in TensorFlow,
we have a service called Cloud
Machine Learning engine to let
you train and serve your model
at scale.
Then a couple months ago we
announced an
open source project
called Kubernetes flow.  Let's
say you have a Machine Learning
framework other than TensorFlow
and you
want to run it on GCP.
You can use it on Google control
engine
or Kubernetes.
On Google clout On Google Cloud
plat
form we have five APIs, that let
you
analyze images, converting audio
to text, translating that text.
I'm going to show you cloud
vision.  This is everything that
vision API let's you do.
At its core the vision API
provides label detention.
For this image it might return
elephant, animal.
Web detection will search the
web for similar images and give
you labels on what it finds.
OCR, optical character
recognition, it let's you find
text, tells where you the text
is and what language it's in.
Logo detection, landmark
detection,
crop hints and explicit content
detect.  This is what a request
to the vision API looks like.
You don't need to know anything
about
how that pretrained model works
under the hood.
You pass it in Google Cloud
storage or
the basic encode Ed image and
tell it
what types of feature detection
it you
want it it to run.  I have an
example in python here.
I created image
image annotateor client.
ML kit, if you want to use ML
kit for Firebase you can call
the vision API from Android or
iOS app and this is an example
of calling it in swift.
So I don't like to get too far
into a
talk without showing a live demo
so if we can switch to the demo.
What we have here is the product
page for the vision API.
We can upload images and see
what the vision API responds.
I'm going to upload an image.
This is a selfie I took seeing
Hamilton.  I live in New York.
Excited to score tickets to
Hamilton.
Let's see what we get back here.
Cranking.  Live demos.  You
never now.  There we go.
We can see that it found my face
in the image so it's able to
identify where my face is,
different features in my face
and detect emotion.  We can see
joy is very likely here.  I was
super excited to be seeing
Hamilton.  What I didn't notice
at first about this is it has
text in it.
When I sent it to the vision API
I didn't know there was text
here but we
can see it's able to abstract
take play bill text from my
image.  Finally in the browser
we can see the entire JSON
response we get back from the
vision API.
This is a great way to try out
the API.  Before you start
writing code, see the response
you get back and I'll provide a
link at the end.  That is the
vision API.  If we can go back
to the slides.
Next I want to talk about the
natural language API which let's
you analyze text with a single
rest API request.
First it let's you extract key
entitys from text.  It also
let's you tells you whether your
text is positive or negative.
And if you want to get more into
the linguistic details of your
text you can use the syntax
analysis method.  And then
content classification.
It will classify your text into
over 700 different categories we
have available.
Here is python codes to call the
natural language API.
It's going to look similar to
the API vision code we saw on
the previous page.  We send in
our text and get back the result
from the model.  Let's jump to a
demo of the natural language
API.
So again this is our products
page for the natural language
API and here we can
enter text directly in this
textbook and see what the
natural language API responds.
I'm going to say I loved Google
I/O but the ML talk was just
okay.
We will see what it says.
This is a review I might find on
a session.  Let's say I wanted
to extract key entities and see
what the sentiment was.
It extracted two entities and we
get a score for each.  The score
is a value from negative 1 to 1
that will tell us overall how
positive or negative is the
sentiment in this entity.
Google I/O got 0.8.  We even get
a link to the Wikipedia page.
ML talk got a neutral score
score zero, because it was just
okay.  And we can look at the
syntax and details, see which
words depend on other words, get
the parts of speech for all the
words in our text.  And if our
text was longer than 20 words we
can make use of this content
categorization feature which you
can try
in the browser and see a list of
all the categories for that.
That is the natural language
API.
If we can go back to the slides.
I'll talk briefly about
companies using these APIs in
production.
Giphy is a website that let's
you
search
for giphs.
It adds search by text
functionality
to all their
gif
.  Hurst
.  Descript let's you transcribe
meetings and interviews.  So all
of these three companies are
using just one API.
We also have seen a lot of
examples of companies combining
different Machine
Learning API
s so seenit ace I crowd sourcedd
video.
They use
video intelligence, speech and
natural language.
Maslo is an audio journaling
app, you
can enter your journal entries
through audio and they're using
speech API to
extract audio and letting you
give
insights about your journal
entries and they're storing the
data.  So that is the natural
language API.
So all of the products I've
talked about
so far have abstracted that
model for you.  A lot of times
when I present on APIs
people ask me those APIs sound
great but
what if I want to train them on
my own custom data.  This is
AutoML Vision.
This loets you train an image
classification model on your own
image data.  This is best seen
with a demo.
For this demo let's say that
I'm a meteorologist.
I want to pro dekt whether
trends and flight plans from
images of clouds.
Can we use the Cloud to analyze
clouds?  And as I have learned
there's many, many different
types of clouds.  And they all
indicate different weather
patterns.  So when I first
started thinking about this demo
I thought maybe I should try the
vision API first and see what I
get back.
So as humans if you look at
these two
images it's obvious to us these
are completely different types
of clouds.
We wouldn't know spl wouldn't
know specifically what times of
clouds these images were but
nothing as specific as cloud
types for these images.
Even for these images of
different clouds we get back
pretty similar labels, sky,
cloud, blue, et cetera.
So this is where AutoML Vision
comes in handy.
It provides a UI to help with
every
step from imparting the data,
labeling,
training it and generating pro
additions.
The best way to see it is by
jumporting the data, labeling,
training it and generating pro
additions.  The best way to see
it is by jumping to a demo.
Here we have the UU for AutoML
Vision.  We import the data.
We put our images in Google
cloud
storage and create a CSV where
the first column is the URL of
the image and the next column is
the
label of of that image.
Then we upload our images and
move over the the labeling tab.
In this model I have five
different types of clouds.  You
can see how many images I have
for each one.  AutoML Vision
only requires ten labels
but they recommend at least 100
for high quality predictions.
The next step is to review my
image labels.
I can see all my cloud pictures
here, see what label they are.
This this one is incorrect I can
go in here and switch it out.
Let's say that I didn't have
time to
label my data set or I have a
massive image data set, I didn't
have time to label it.
I can make use of this human
labeling service that will label
your images for you and in just
a couple days you'll get back a
label image data set.
The next part is to train your
model.
And you can choose between a
base or advanced model.  I'll
talk about that more in a
moment.  To train it all you do
is press this train button,
simple as that.
Once your model is trained
you'll get an e-mail and the
next thing you want to do is see
how this model performed using
some common Machine Learning
metrics.  So I'm not going to go
into all of them here but I do
want the highlight
the confusion matrix.  If it
looks confusing call it a
confusion matrix.  For a good
confusion matrix we want to
see a strong diagonal from top
to left.
It split our images for us into
training and testing.
It took most of our images, used
those to train and model and
reserved a subset of our images
to see how the model performed
on images it had never seen
before.
What this is telling us is for
all of our cloud images in our
test set our
model was able to identify 76%
of them correctly.
On the train tab you saw the
base and advance models.  I've
trained both so we are looking
at the advance model here.  I
can use the UI to see how
different versions of my model
performed and compare it.
So we would expect that the
advanced model would perform
better across the board so let's
take a look.  It looks like it
did indeed perform a lot better
for most all of the categories
here.
23% increase for this 1, 11% for
this one.
Hey, wait, if we look at our
Alto stratus images it did worse
on that.
What this is pointing out is
there may be problems with our
training immamgs here so the
advance model did a better job
of identifying where there's
problems with our training data
sesmt our model is only as good
as the training data we give it.
14% of our Alto stratus clouds
are
being miss labeled
as cume lus clouds
ulous clouds.
These are pretty confusing
images.
This can identify where I need
too go back and improve my
training data.
The next part is generating
predictions on new data.  I'm
going to take this go back and
improve my training data.  The
next part is generating
predictions on new data.  I'm
going to take this image of a
sirus cloud and see what our
model predicts.  It has never
seen this image before.  It
wasn't used during training and
we
will seal how it perform
cirrus cloud and see what our
model predicts.  It has never
seen this image before.  It
wasn't used during training and
we will see how it performs.
So the UI is one way you can
generate predictions once your
model has been trained.  Chances
are you probably want to build
an app that's going to query
your
trained model and there's a
couple different ways to do
this.  I want the highlight the
vision API here.  If you
remember the vision API request
from a couple slides back you'll
notice this doesn't look much
different.
All I need to add is this custom
detection label parameter and I
get an ID for that trained model
that only I have access to or
anybody that I shared my project
with.
If I have an app that is just
detecting whether or not there's
a Cloud and image
but then say I want to upgrade
my app, I
don't have to change much at all
about my app architecture.
I just need to modify the
request JSON a little bit.  So
that is auto ML vision.  If we
can go back to the slides.  A
little bit about companies that
are using Auto ML vision and
have been part of the alpha.
Disney is the first example.
They trained a model on
different Disney characters,
product categories and colors
and they're integrating that
into their search engine to give
users more accurate results.
Urban outfiters have a similar
use case.
They train a model to create
different
set of
product attributes and are using
it to give users better search
results.
The last example is zoological
society of London.  They have
cameras deploy all over the wild
and they built a model to
automatically tag all the
wildlife they're seeing across
those cameras so they don't need
someone to manually review it.
So the two products I've talked
about so
far the APIs and AutoML have
entirely abstracted the model
from us.  We don't know anything
about how that model works under
the hood but let's say you have
a more custom prediction task
that is specific to your data
set or use case.  One example is
let's say you have just
launched a new product at your
company, you're seeing it posted
on social media and you want to
identify where in an image that
product is located.  You are
need to train a model on your
own data to do that.
Lelts say you have a lot of
blogs come
in and you want to analyze those
logs to
find am nomlys in your
application.  We have two tools
to help you do this.  TensorFlow
for building your models and
Machine Learning engine for
training and serving those
models at scale.
So from the beginning the Google
brain team wanted everyone in
the industry to be able to
benefit from all the Machine
Learning products so they made
TensorFlow an open source
project on
GitHub and up take has been
phenomenal.
It has over 90,000 GitHub stars.
It just crossed over 13 million
down loads.  Because it's open
sourced you can train and serve
your TensorFlow models anywhere.
So once you built your
TensorFlow model you need to
think about training it and
then generating predictions at
scale also known as serving.  So
if you're app becomes a major
hit, you're getting thoulgs of
prediction requests per minute
you need to find a
way to serve that model at scale
sands of prediction requests per
minute you need to find a way to
serve that model at scale.
Because TensorFlow is over
source you can train them
anywhere but this is
about Google Cloud platform.  On
Cloud machine engine learning
you
can run distributed training
with GPUs and TPUs.  You can
also deploy your trained model
to Machine Learning engine and
then use
the ML engine API to access
scalable online and batch
prediction for your model.  One
of the great things is there's
no lock in.  Let's say I want to
make use of ML engine for
training my model but then I
want to download my model and
service it someplace else.
That's easy to do and I can do
the reverse as well.  I'm going
to talk about two different
times of custom models using
tvrs.
The first is transfer learning
which let's us update an xating
trained model use our own data
and then talking about training
a model from scratch using only
your data.
So transfer learning is great if
you need a custom model but
don't have enough training data.
It let's you utilize an existing
retrained model to do something
similar to what we are trying to
do and take the
weights of that and take a
couple of layers with our own
training data.
So I wanted to build an end to
end
example showing how to train a
model and building an app.
I know a little bit of swift so
I
decided to build an iOS app.
You upload a picture of your
pet, it's
able to detect where the pet is
in the image and what type of
breed it's.
There's a library of top of
TensorFlow
to let you do object detection
which is identifying a bounding
box.  I trained the model on
Machine Learning engine.
And then I used a couple of
Firebase APIs to build a front
end for my app.  This is a full
architecture diagram.  IOS
client is actually a pretty tlin
client.  What it's doing is it's
uploading images to closed
storage for Firebase
and I've got a cloud function
that is on that bucket so that
function is going to
be triggered any time a image is
uploaded.
It sendss to Machine Learning
engine for prediction and the
prediction I get back is going
to be a confidence value,
label and bounding box detail
for where that pet is in my
image.
I store the metadata in fire
store.
Here is an example showing how
the front end works.  So this is
a screen shot of fire store.
We can see when ever my image
data is uploaded to fire store I
write the new image with the box
around it to a Cloud storage
bucket.
So that was an example of
transfer
learning learning.
Say we have a custom task and
can
build enough data entirely from
scratch.
This is a demi of a model that
predicts the price of wine.
Can we predict the price?
This is what an example input
and prediction for a model would
be.
One reason this is well-suited
for Machine Learning is I can't
write rules to determine what
the price of this wine should
be.
I can't say any wine with
the vanilla in the description
is going to be a cheap wine.  So
I want to see if I can build a
Machine Learning model to
extract insights from that data.
Because I'm training this model
from scratch there's no existing
model out there that does
exactly this task.
I'm going to need a lot of data.
I use Kaggle.  It's part of
Google.  If you're new to
Machine Learning and looking for
interesting data sets to play
around with I recommend checking
out Kaggle.  It has a wine
review data set.
I found this on 150,000
different kinds of wine.  For
each wine it has a lot of data
on description, the points
rating, the price, et cetera.
I'm just using the description,
the variety and the price for
this model.
The next step is to choose API
I'm going the use to build my
model which TensorFlow API and
the type of model I want to use.
So I chose to use the Tf.Keras
API.
And the TensorFlow API includes
a full implementation of Keras.
It makes it easy for us to
define the layers of our model.
You can also use a lower level
TensorFlow API.
So I chose to use the tf.
Keras API and chose to build a
wide and deep model.  It's a
fans way of saying I'm going to
represent the inputs to my model
in two different ways.
A linear model, that's the wide
part.  That's good at memorizing
relationships between inputs.
And a deep neural net which is
good at generalizing data it
hasn't seen before.
The input to our wide model is
going to be sparse around the
input to the
deep is going to be dense
embedding vectors.
This is all using the Keras
functional API to define the
wide model.  I'm going the use
what is called a bag of words
representation.  What this does
is takes all the words that
occur across all my wine
descriptions and I'm going to
choose the top -- I choose to
use the top 12,000 because this
is a hyper parameter you can
tune.
Each input to my model is going
to be
at 12,000 element vector with
ones and zeros indicating
whether or not the word
from my vocabulary is present in
this description.
This wide model just takes into
account whether or not this word
from my vocabulary is present in
that specific description.  This
type of input is going to look
like this.
It's going to be a 12,000
element bag of words vector.
The way I'm representing my
variety,
this is going to be a 40 element
one hot
vector with each index and the
vector corresponding to a
different variety of wine.  I'm
going to output to my model
indicating what the price of
that wine is.
If I just wanted to use the wide
model I
can take the wide model I have
here, run
run training and evaluation on
it using
Keras but I fund better accuracy
using wide and deep.
Word em betting let's us define
the relationships between words
in vector space.  Words that are
similar to each other are going
to be closer together in vector
space.
There's lots of reading out
there so I'm not going to focus
on the details.
I can choose
the dimensionality of that
space.  In this case you can see
I used an eight dimensional
embedding space.
I obviously can't feed the text
directly into my model.  I need
to put night a format that my
model can understand.
I encoded each word as an
integer.  This what is the input
to my deep model is going to
look like.
The inputs need to be the same
lengths but not all my
description are the same Lindt.
None of my descriptions are
longer than 170 words.
If they're shorter I'll tack
that vectors with zeros.  We are
still predicting the price.
Using the Keras functional API
it's relatively straightforward
to combine
the outputs and my combined
model.
I choose to do Machine Learning
engine.
First is to package and put it
in Google Cloud storage.  I put
it in trainer director.
I put my wine in data directory
and
have this defining the
dependencies that my model is
going to use.
To run that training job I can
use G
Cloud which is our Google Cloud
CLI for interacting with a
number of different Google Cloud
products.
I save my model file which is a
binary file to Google cloud
storage.
Let's see a demo of generating
some predictions on that model.
I'm going to use a tool called
co-lab
and this is
a cloud hosted Jupiter notebook.
What I've done is saved that
model
file in Google Cloud storage and
now I'm going to save
predictions.  Here we are just
imparting libraries
we are going to use, I'm loading
my
model, next step is to load the
tokenizeer from my model.  This
is just an index associating all
the words in my vocabulary with
a number
and I'm loading my variety and
coder, too.  I'm going to ignore
that warning.  Here I'm going to
load in some raw data.  What I
have here is data on five
different wines.  I've got the
description, the variety and the
associated price for each of
these wines.
And I wanted to show you what
the input looks like for each of
these.  Now we need to encode
each of those into the wide and
deep format that our model is
expecting.  We have this
vocabulary look up.
I'm printing a subset of it
here.  This is going to be
12,000 elements long for the top
12,000 words in our vocabulary
and Keras has utilitys to
help us extract those top words.
And each index corresponding to
a different variety.  Let's see
what the input to our wide model
looks like.
So the finish thing is our text.
This is a bag of words vector.
It's a 12,000 element vector
with zeros and ones indicating
the presence
or absence of different words in
the vocabulary.
I believe that first wine was a
pinot noir.  We can confirm yes
that was.  So that's the input
to our wide model.  Our deep
model we are just encoding all
the words from that first
description as integers and
padding it with zeros.
All I need to do to generate
predictions on Keras model is
called dot predict.  What I'm
doing here is now going to loop
through those predictions and
see how the model performed
compared to the actual price.
We can see it did a pretty good
job on the first 1, 46 compared
to 48.
This one was about $30 off but
it was still able to understand
it was a higher priced wine and
it did pretty well on the rest
of these as well.  I'll have a
link to this at the end.
You can go to this URL, enter
your own wine descriptions and
see how the model perform also.
If we can go back to the slides
I'll
talk about a few companies using
TensorFlow and Machine Learning.
The first example is
is Rolls-Royce
.  Oh cado is the UK's largest
grocery delivery service.
They got tons of customer
support e-mails every day.
They built a model to predict
whether
the e-mail requires an urgent
response or no response at all.
Airbus has built a custom image
classification model to identify
things
in satellite I imagery.  So I
know I covered a ton of
different products.
I wanted to give you a summary
of what resources all these
products require.  These are
four resources I thought of that
you need to solve a Machine
Learning problem.  There's
probably more that I don't have
on here.
Training data, mobile code,
training and serving
infrastructure and overall how
long is this task going to take
you?  So if you look at our
Machine Learning APIs, great
thing about these you don't need
any training data.  You can
start generating prediction on
one image.  You don't need to
write any of the
model code you don't need to
provide any
serving or serving
infrastructure and you can
probably get started with these
in less than a day.
The cool thing about AutoML is
you will be providing your own
training data.  It will take a
little more time
because you would need to spend
time
processing images, uploading
them
to the cloud and maybe labeling
them.
And finally if we think about a
custom model TensorFlow running
on Cloud ML engine you would
need a lot of training
data, you will have to write a
lot of the model code yourself
and you would think about
whether you want to run your
training and service jobs on
premise,
and obviously this process will
take a little bit more time.
Finally if you remember only
three
things from this presentation,
first
thing you can use
a pretrained API to accomplish
common Machine Learning tasks.
Second thing, if you want to
build an image classification
API, train on your
own data, use AutoML Vision.
I'm interested to hear if you
have a
specific use case for Auto ML
vision.  Find me afterwards.
I'll be in the Cloud sandbox
area.
You can build a TensorFlow model
with your own data.  So here is
a lot of great resources
covering everything I talked
about today.  I'll let you take
a picture of that slide.
The video will also be up after
so you can grab it from there as
well.  And that's all I've got.
Thank you.
(Applause).
.
"Realtime captioning on this
screen" .
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Grand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We will be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.  If you've registered
for the next
session in this room, we ask
that you
please clear the room and return
via the registration line
outside.  Thank you.
.
>>
What's new with constraint
layout and
Android studio design tools.
New With Constraint Layout and
Android Studio Design Tools
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
.
>> Hi.
(Applause).
>> All right. So good
afternoon, everyone.
My name Nick has Nicholas
.  You might have noticed we
released a really cool -- there
was a session this morning, it's
on YouTube, check it out.  It's
really cool.
So we are going to talk about
the walk
we have been walking on this
past year,
specifically we will focus on
sample data and we will also
talk
about constraint layout 2.2 and
what is coming up with these
libraries.  First for the
section on the layout
editor, Vadim will present for
you.
>> VADIM CAEN: Thank you. Hi,
everyone.
To start with we are going to
talk about layout editor.
It's a graphical cool without
having to write any XML and it's
supposed to make you more
productive.
So what is nice with the layout
editor it also works with your
custom views.
So if in your code you have a
custom
view, the nice thing is that any
custom view from your project
will appear in the Palette.
Our goal is to make you more
productive.
We added some nice features this
year to do so.
The first one I want to talk
about is the conversion.  So if
you right click on a view you'll
see the conversion option that
will make this pop up appear and
you'll be able to
select
one of the constraint component.
And this view is contextual so
if you
right click on a view which is
not a
view group it will show some
non-view group views.
The next thing I want to talk
about is
the navigation between included
layout
.  If you double click on the
component it will jump
automatically.
And if you jump to the arrow it
will jump back.
This is handy to be fast between
layouts.
The layout editor
is really for constraint layout
and
constraint layout is a great
layout.  You might not want to
write all your XML by hand.
What you should do instead is
take all
the menus we have in the layout
editor to generate this XML for
you.  Again, right click on the
view and
then you can use the -- align
any of the top option to choose
your option.  We have many of
them so feel free to check them
after this session and it's
going to be make you more
productive.
Most of you be probably
populating your layout, you have
data from the
internet and you want to
populate them.
To serve this issue Diego will
talk about sample layout.
>> DIEGO PEREZ: Before we talk
about
sample layout let's talk about
the tools attributes.
You actually use them to give
information to the Android
studio.  We are not going to
talk about all of
them but let's cover one
example.  You probably have seen
this.
So in your string file you get a
warning
saying you haven't translated in
a particular stream.  That's it,
the error is gone.  But there
might be situation where you
don't want this.  It could be
it's the name of the application
and you don't want the
translate it in every single
language, only certain
languages.
You can basically tell look I
know
about the server but I don't
want you to tell me about it
because it's fine.  So that is
one example.  There are many
others.  But what we want to
talk about now is
actually design time attributes.
This is the tools attributes
that I talked about.
There are additional information
and content to the layout
editor.  Let's see one example.
So in this case what we have is
we created our Toolbar.
We had to keep the layout on its
own so we use constraint layout.
This is how it will look.
What you can see is the Toolbar
without any context but you done
see the layout so you don't know
how it going to look.  So there
is something we can do.
You can again tell the layout
editor this layout is going to
be included in this other layout
here.
So using this attribute to show.
We are letting the layout know
that we
want to embed this header into
the main layout.
And that way we can see the
context so
now when we have editing we know
if the colors match we can tweak
our design and
see how every chain impacts our
layout.
And the best thing is again you
can do it -- you can edit it
right there.  You don't have to
see with that blank space or
anything like that.
Let's see another interesting
use of this.
When you have the text view this
is
usually what you get so you have
hello world and that's it.  But
you can tell to the layout
editor that you know this is
going to look different and do
you that but using the tools.
In in case we are replacing both
the text and the text color.
And we are telling the layout
editor at run time this is going
to look different.
And we are good to see how this
is very useful.
When you are in the recycler
view this
is what you get by default.  You
can see how it's laid out but
it's not very useful.  It's just
a list of elements with a lot of
empty space.
We can use the tools attributes,
you basically let the layout
editor know.  This is the layout
that I'm going to use.  You have
probably seen list item many
times, very simple.  You can say
we can do other things.
We can tell the layout editor
how is this going to look with
five elements?  All these things
you usually cannot do them in
the layout editor because these
are things that happen at run
time so usually the source of
information for a
recycler view is an adapter.  It
might depend on many things.
So doing this you give us
context and
then the layout editor will
render correctly similar to what
you have in run time.
So let's now go into sample
data.
Sample data was introduced in 3.
0.  It helps you to actually
populate data that is not
available at this time.  So in
this case what we are doing is
telling the layout editor that I
want to use the theme property
and get the data
from this data source which we
call a sample.
And that data source is simply a
file with a list of colors that
you see there.
So what happens in the design
time is the layout editor will
get a different color for every
item.  So that looks better.
But we can do more.
So let's see how you create that
file.
You go to your project, new,
sample
data directory and that's how we
create the directory what we are
going to put every data serve
that we have.
We want colors so new file and
then we
name it and we just put the list
of colors and that's it.  It's
that simple.  Now you can use it
in any property.
So this is one of the types of
data sources that you can use in
sample data.  So it's basically
a list of colors.  You can have
lists of any kind of that
you want like regular text and
just replace it.  But you can
have other things more
interesting like you can have
dimensions, so if you have
dimensions using the tools
attributes you can to the layout
editor I want to use this
dimension and I wants it to be
different for every item and you
can do that using sample data.
We also have other types of data
sources.  You can have images.
You're create it in a similar
way.  Instead of a file you
create a director and drop all
your images in there.  And
recycler view will get a
different image for every item
so it's very simple.
The last part I want to tell you
about is JSON files.  JSON files
is a similar way to the
list that we had before but it
allows to do something, you can
have all your data together in
one place.
You can add maybe context about
why a particular item is like
that or you can
even get a sample from your AVI
and put it into your sample
data.
We have a list of notes.
We have a title and an album.
You can reference any of those
elements.  Let's see how to do
that.  In this case what we are
telling the
layout editor is I want you to
replace
text of design time and do it
with the
name of the JSON file and then
the node that we saw before.  In
this case we are doing it with
title and album.  Remember this
will change depending on the
name of the JSON file.  It
doesn't even need to be called
JSON.  If you don't want to
provide your own
data sources, Android studio
will also provide -- it already
comes with a set
of predefined ones so you don't
have to create your own.  We
give you a set of them, we give
you
names, and we also give you a
set of images.
For example you can use Avatars
and you don't need to create
images.  You can just use the
ones that we give you.
Again, how to use that is very
similar.  The only difference
that you can see
here is we added tools of the
data source.
Instead of being a sample now is
a tool sample.
Using
syntax completion you can see
all the data sources we have.
In 3.2 we added new features.
So everything we saw was already
available in 3 L3 L.
.
>> Sample data is a great tool
so we decided to put a UI on top
of it.  So what does it look
like?  I'm sure most of you
already did that so we have
image view.
You're taking it from the pallet
and the pallet.
Since you started your project
you
only have
the launcher icon available.
You have the sample data and you
can
pick any resource data from your
project.
So now our image looks better
and we can see it in our
recycler view.
But what if you want to make
some change to this sample data?
What if I want to use one simple
image for myself?
We introduced in 3.2 a new
design time helper.
So here I'm going to uncheck and
this
will give me the ability to
select only one image from my
set.  And I can try it out with
any e-mail from this set.  But
now let's say we want to give it
another look and pick images
from another data set.
So we can just use this and
select another data set and here
we go, our recycler view has a
brand new look so it's nice to
preview what it would look like.
So you can always jump back to
the resource picker and there's
a full set
of resources available by
clicking the
button on the bottom of the pop
up.  And the same options are
available.  If you select a
sample data on the
resource picker it will populate
design image so it will be
removed at one time.
We have the same design time
helper for text view.
So here I'm just selecting
different
sets for each view and as you
can see on
the recycler view each item is
taking one instance of each own
set for each item.  And finally
we have also added this
feature for recycler view
.  You can just jump back to the
file and preview your changes.
All the design time attributes
are automatically populated so
you don't have to do anything
and take full advantage of
sample data.
But it's even more helpful if
you use it with constraint
layout.  Nicholas is going to
come on stage and
do a deep dive with constraint
layout.
>> NICHOLAS ROARD: We released
constraint layouts officially
last year.  So if you don't know
about it, it's a
library that allows you to
create your interfaces.
And we tried to use flat
hierarchies which is coming very
handy for automations.
It's compatible essentially
everywhere.  It's small. .
It comes with
a great UI builder.  Please try
to use it.
It's something we are working
onto help make your life easier.
We release it constraint layout
1.2 last year.
You can set up your0 last year.
You can set up your UI, there's
a lot of capabilities here.
And there's some helper object
like guidelines to help you set
up your screen.
So it's already very full set of
features.
But a month ago we related
constraint layout 1.1 with a lot
of fixes, improvements, new
features, now ways of increasing
your layout.  There's one which
allows you to
position an element relative to
a set of elements so whatever
the position and
dimension of those elements that
element on the right is going to
position correctly.
So essentially with constraint
layout 1.1 we have really
flexible layout, something that
should essentially lept you
express any UI.
And you can just add to it yourt
you express any UI.  And you can
just add to it your
project, we are now shifting so
it
should be very easy for you to
use it.
But I think a lot of you here or
in this room to hear me talk
about
constraint layout
are in this room to hear me talk
about constraint layout 2.0.
It's a great base.  It gives
flexibility that you need to
create a UI and comes with a UI
builder.
One of the concepts was the
concept of helper object.
Object that even though you can
manipulate them into the UI
builder, they do not appear on
your screen when you run the
application but essentially
they help you create your UI so
one of them is the guideline
object, the
designer typically specifies a
UI with
horizontal lines, well you can
simply replicate those in your
UI so it's a lot easier to set
up your screen.  With 1.1 we
have the barrier I talked about.
And what is nice with those
helper objects we have for them
in the UI builder so you can
manipulate them and
add elements to those helper
objects in the component tree by
dragging elements into them.
Something you might not realize
is that
those helpers objects are not
gibberish.
They keep reference to the views
so we
still keep the view tree very
flat.  Because they're just
references we can have one
object being referenced in
multiple helpers.
And very interesting for us.
You can think about the helpers
a way
of keeping a reference to a
bunch of
views, you can still get flat
hierarchy
and the helper gives you a way
of encapsulating.  2.
0 woe are going to expose those
helpere are going to expose
those helpers.  If you have a
person on your project
similar to what we have with
custom
views they will be able to
present.  We calculated three
board categories for the helper.
One category is layout
manipulation.  Helper that is
going to help you increase
create a layout.  Another is
going to help you after the
layout is done so post layout.
And we have helpers because
helpers
are views or can be views as
well, helpers that we can use to
do some specific rendering.
For the virtual layouts there's
a concept that we are really
keen on.
The idea is that the helper is
going to set the constraint for
you.
The simplest example I can think
of is a linear helper.  If you
created a chain in constraint
layout one that will allow you
to do exactly the same thing but
you manipulate it like the
layouts, for instance.  The only
difference is you have all
the features that chains provide
you.  The way you use them it's
very easy.  It's a normal view.
You can constrain the view
itself but the only thing you
need here is that list of ID's
that you reference.
We have a virtual layout that we
launch with 2.
2 that essentially implements
the flex box layout semantics.
Those are pretty useful but at
the same time I think pretty
expected.
We come up with additional use
cases.
So one example of post layout
object
is
a flying object.  You can
reference this object with a
flying decorator and that's all.
So no code, it's purely
derivative,
add that to your file, reference
that object and it will animate
on first launch.  We have
another object that's very
powerful and layers, essentially
a lot of things.
It It has a set of views and
apply
operation to them so there's a
bunch of graphic operation that
you can apply and
we will do the math.
You can also set it up so it
takes by default the views it
references and you can set up a
background very easily that way.
Another use case that will be
supposed you can use the layer a
little bit like
you would use layers in
graphical photo editors to a
bunch of layers to specify
your elements and when you are
okay with those elements
constraints you can lock
that layer and be sure to modify
them.  So it's a very powerful
helper.
Here is a quick example on how
it would
look by drawing a back ground.
And we set the constraint
manually
.  Just to prove that we have a
flat tree, we can apply this
operation that
I'm talking about and everything
will
just go but the background stays
where it is.
Another
useful decorator is circular
reveal.  It does what it says.
The typical effect that you've
been
familiar with with design, if I
press the button, the
interesting thing here
is that you notice that it only
applies to the element
reference.
We have the ones that are not
referenced.  We did not apply to
them f you play
with circular reveal you see
it's a bit tricky to do that.
Interesting here as well we are
not
creating our own circular
reveal, we are
justing into just using the
normal circular reveal.  It's a
way to use your layouts.
So on that same idea we have
decorators that are helperss
that are here to draw things.
And same things we reference use
and you can draw something with
it.
So that's confusing in terms of
what type of affect you can get
with that.
You may want an affect like
that, like a lava lamp affect.
And what you see is the result
of that affect will depend on
the position of
those blobs but the final
rendering has to take into
account all of them.  And that
would normally be very difficult
to achieve.  You can think about
it that way, you
have a canvas that you paint on.
You'll have actually some image
views that are essentially
sitting on top of
that and they're normal image
views, normal views, you can
apply the usual things.  But we
put them on background to be
transparent and then we use a
decorator to draw the
background.  You can easily get
an affect like that.
A little slower, there you goep
you go.
Just to show you
the bots are correct we still
have our images.
Another type of decorator is the
bottom panel decorator.
Let's say that you may have
created by using a chain, very
easy.  If you like to set a
background on
those objects and maybe change
the colors.
You can simply apply this
decorator.  And because we can
do a little more interesting
stuff here, I can show you what
it may look like when you click
on those buttons.
So just to give you an idea of
the type
of effects you can get with
decorator
s, so I'm clicking on this, I
can press
that, I press is and there's a
circular reveal.
Just to give you an idea of what
you can do.  What is very
interesting here is that
if you look at it in studio and
if I
zoom under component tree, you
will
notice that actually we mostly
adjust
views and just a bunch of
helpers.  There's actually no
code here so it's
a really useful addition to try
to
really separate the field with
the
actual -- your actual data and
your actual application.
So to summarize with the
helpers, you
can tag your views with those,
you can encapsulate and it's all
declarative.
You have been probably playing
with
constraints on the constraint
layout 1.1.  And if you switch
between two of those states, you
can animate them.
So that's verystates on the
constraint layout 1.1.  And if
you switch between two of those
states, you can animate them.
So that's very nice but
initiating
those things is a little
cumbersome.  So in 2.
0 we will have a separate file
that let's you specify states
because that's basically what
they are.
I have a layout that is
different pre presentation,
different states.
So the way you would use them is
by description.
You condense by state ID and
that's it.
One nice thing is that you can
specify a region when a specific
constraint set is going to be
applied.
And by plugging that into
onconfiguration changed, I'm
showing that on the Chromebook,
you'll see
automatically depending on the
size of
the Window will switch layouts.
If you want a little more fancy,
you can on the prelayout change
plug transition manager and it
will animate the layout
transition.
So I think we have devices,
Chrome books, es that's the type
of use case
that it's going to be more and
morethat's the type of use case
more useful.
So to quickly recap on
constraint layout, we have the
helpers, we have the
virtual layouts and decorators,
we also
have stuff I haven't talked
about like for manipulating the
constraints
directly and we have
motion layouts.
I'm happy to introduce John.
>> JOHN HOFORD: Thanks.
I'm excited to show you
guys motion layout.
So let's kind of get into it.
It starts off with a sub class
of
constraint layout called motion
layout.  It's a layout that has
all the properties of constraint
layout but the
whole trick with animateing
between two constraint sets,
that will be done for
you by emotionally motion
layout.  If you have two
constraint sets it will switch
between them and animate between
them by itself.
But notice because it's a
constraint
layout, you can actually use the
helpers that were shown there.
But it also provides you with
the
ability to edit the custom
attributes of the system.
So notice the blue light there,
it's
changing because it's a custom
attribute in the system.
So constraint sets now can have
custom attributes, allows to you
animate anything.
One of the other things that it
does is
it allows you to control on
touch directly.
So it will manage your touch
events by
tracking your velocity of your
finger and matching it to other
velocity of
views in the system and
naturally give you a smooth
transition between them by a
touch.
We also support helpers because
it's a constraint layout.
Nicholas just showed they're
there, too.  They can work
together and apart.
Now let's change the transition
a little bit.  We want to move
the eye into the middle of the
screen but if we look closely
there's a bit of a problem here.
You see the arrow clashes with
the eye.
We have to fix that.  The way we
do that is a feature we call key
frames.  Essentially if we have
a beginning and
an end of a path, we can distort
the path by adding a key frame.
Once we add the key frame, it
will avoid the path.
Which is pretty cool.
So now we have a motion scene.
It has constraint sets.
It has on touch, key frames,
custom attributes.
With a little flag on your
device you can see the path of
all the objects you've set on
it.  So you can understand what
all your views are doing on
device.
So one of the nice things we
support is
nesting of constraint sets of
motion layouts.
In this particular example we
have two
views being animated by a third
view.
They're both constraint motion
layouts and they're being being
driven by a
third emotionally
motion layout.
The top view is a fade to black
but
this is an animated view that
was custom written by Nicholas
that is being driven
by a motion layout because it
implements on progress method.
So you can drag your own custom
animations directly from motion
layout.
So one of the things it's really
good at is synchronizing
motions.  Anything that is very
complex sequences of many things
moving on the screen it will
handle it and will also allow
you to interact with it with the
touch.
So we added one more thing to
the system, something we call
cycles.
This is the ability to build
into the
key frames
s on sill
oscillatetory cycles.
I can take one and have it roll
because it's oscillated.
Or I can have a different
effect, it can bounce along the
edge.
I got bored and had that one
flying around.  [Laughter].
Another typical example you put
a little shake at the end.
So now one of the cool things is
we build editors.
So we are building an editor for
that thing.  We call it the
motion editor.
It's part of the design surface.
But now you'll be able to do
those edits directly in the
design surface.
So kind of to take you through
how you
would do that in the design
surface,
based on constraint layout you
just just
create your constraints for your
first
constraint set, switch to the
second, edit constraints for the
second set.  If you hit play it
will show the
animation between those two
constraint sets.
There's a check box to enable
showing you the path so now you
can see the path.  But how would
you add a key frame?
Just position the cursor where
you want
it, add the type of key frame
that you
want to add, and you can just
distort the position by
selecting the key frame and
moving it around on this screen.
Let's do that one more time so
you can see it.
Just select a position, any
position,
create a key frame, and then we
just
move it
it.  So here is much more
complex motions.  All animated.
This has quite a few key frames
in it
designed to let you set
transparency on some things,
move them around.
But it all worked in the IDE.
Thank you.
(Applause)
.
>> So one last thing.
You probably are here to try all
those things.
So a lot of that is actually 3.
2.
All the sample data we showed
you, all
the current integration with 1.
1, go, try it out.
We released
canary 14 model this Tuesday so
give it a try.
The library with emotionallyout
we are doing it in a few days
hopefully.
And motion editor it's an on
going but we are excited about
it.
So think about it, there is
codelabs
as well
for the Chromeos resize.  We
also want to hear from you in
general.  We are reachable, but
for this particular session
there's feedback you can fill.
We also have an office hour this
after even when after the
session.  Please come see us.
That completes our talk.  Thank
you, very much.
(Applause).
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.
Grand ambassadors will assist
with
helping you move.  If you
registered for the next session
in this room we ask that you
clear the
room and enter via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
.
Paging with recycler view
:  Managing
infinite lists with recycler
view and
paging
With Recycler View:  Managing
Infinite Lists With Recycler
View and Paging
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Page with recycler view:
Managing
infinite lists with recycler
view and paging.
.
>> At this time please find your
your seat.  Our session will
begin soon.
>> CHRIS CRAIK: Hey, I'm Chris
Craik
from the Android framework team.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: My name is
Yigit.  I also work with the
framework team.  Today we are
going talk take about
managing infinite lists and
recycler view.
Pretty much every app as a list
of something they want to
display.  Let's see how you
would model a list like this.
So you'll have a view model but
keep
the list of items so it survives
configuration change.  You put
your data into database so that
your application works off line.
And of course you have some
component where you pull the
data from.
Usually data is dynamic, it
changes.
So how does this change the
database
to return live data list of
things or observeible list of
things so you can have updates?
For instance, if you put the
updated
version of records from your
database
and realizes this a query
observing this
table, let me reveal the result,
fast
forward the the view model and
you can
pull from the view model and
update the animations.  This
looks cool but there is actual a
a problem here.  There's
something we don't like.  To
better understand the issue
let's look at the interaction
between the database and the UI.
When I mention that database is
going to reveal the result, it
is going to
reveal all of the results so if
you ask for the users ordered by
their last name
and if you have 10,000 users,
it's going
to create 10,000 users, pats
over to the UI and it's very
inefficient because user only
sees 8 to 10 items, why would
you create 10,000 items?  So we
don't like it.  We want to
change this.
What are we looking for here?
First we like that convenience,
it's
so nice to tell the database
give me a
live list of user, we want to
handle multiple layers, be able
to bring the data from the
server, put in the
database and the UI and this
should be very easy to
implement.  We want it to be
fast.
We don't want to do any big
chunk of work.  It should be
efficient.
We want it to be life cycle
aware so if user is not looking
at the screen it shouldn't do
any work.
Last but not least we want it
tot be flexible.  Everyone has
their different API, different
data structures.  Our solutions
should work with all of those
things.
Now if you go back to our first
example,
how do we implement these lists
if we don't use paging?
If you're
using, you return it to your
live list of users.  You hold
the reference to it and serve it
to your UI.
Your activity you would use this
list but if you're not following
our releases closely you may not
have heard about it.  This works
on that one.
List adapter is a recycler view
adapter that displays a list.
So if you have the recycler view
on the right, when you call the
list adapter it just displays
it.
The nice thing is if you call
the same with a different list
it's going to calculate the
difference between these
two lists on a background and
update the UI with the correct
animations.
It's available in recycler view
27.
1 and same function exists in
the async list differ.
Okay.  Let's go back to our
example.  We have our adapter.
We observe the live data, send
the list to the adapter.
When we see the adepter we need
to give it a call back.  It has
two functions.  First it can
check if two items are
equal identically and other one
checks
whether checks whether their
contents are equal or not.
Once you have that you can call
the get item function, obtain
the item in the list and do
whatever you want with it.
Super simple.
>> CHRIS CRAIK: We have seen
what that looks like but you
also started with with this is
not good enough.  Let's see what
it looks like when using a new
paging library.  The most
important component of the
paging library is the page list.
This is a list that load data in
pages asynchronouslily.
It's backed by a data source,
swaps it in, and updates the
list.
So this serves as a replacement
to the
list in all the examples we have
done before.  We have this view
model.
Let's swap out the list with a
page list and go back to our
Dao.
We want to ask our Dao can you
give me
a live data of a page list but
there's an issue with this.  So
if we look over at what the data
looks like on the database side,
you could imagine paging this in
one way and you could imagine
paging this in a different way.
There's an interesting decision
here,
you showing large items or tiny
items where you want to have a
lot at once?
The page needs to be
configurable to serve every
app's needs.
So instead room can produce this
data
source that back pages it that
way it can access it and load
the data directly into the page
list.
Because we say we want multiple
of them, we want something that
is observable.  We create a new
data source.
All right.
So instead of the live data page
list,
what the user Dao provides us
here is a data source factory
keyed off of imageer because we
are using positions.
So we go back to our view model
here and define how are we going
to load this data?  It's not
much code.
We just say get the data source
factory and use this live page
list builder class from the
library to create a live data.
The minimum amount of data you
need to pass is page size.
Here we have 30.  Now all the
repository changes are done.
Let's go to the activity.
So now we are using list adapter
before.  You change this into a
page list adapter.
It's the exact same thing as
list adapter.
It's loading the pages as
content is internally loading
those page list.
So if we look at how we
implement this list adapter
though, we would have to
switch over the new page list
adapter
and use the exact same dif code.
The only thing that changes is
the user object becomes nullible
and we will get into why in just
a little bit.
So let's go through how you can
do further configuration because
we don't stop at just page size.
So the code that we showed
before
creating a live page list
builder you
can just pass a minimum page
size and that's the minimum
amount of data you need to pass
but you can also create a
configuration object where you
can declare more.
You might set an initial load
size hint.  This suggests the
initial load is larger to make
that initial load avoid initial
page stretches immediately after
you've fetched it.  Another
thing you can change is
pre-Fitch prefetch distance.
You can configure this.
You can also control place
holders which are an important
part of this library so let's
start talking about those.
Place holders false is the
expectation you might have where
you load the page, the recycler
view has access to the number of
items you've loaded and you have
a big scroll bar.  The user can
scroll through it.
Once they get to the bottom,
there's no more data.
Once the page loads the scroll
bar jumps.  We also support a
completely different type of
paging.
If you asked for place holders
and
this is the default, we will
present the list like this.
The scroll bar is smaller and
that's because we are presenting
the entire data set immediately.
As the user scrolls down you'll
see there are unloaded items and
those are presented as nuls in
the adapter.  These items as the
data eventually
loads, display and you'll get a
nice animation from that.
So let's talk about place
holders, they don't work
everywhere but we think they're
useful in a lot of cases.  The
user can control past what is
loaded.  They don't have to hit
a block at the end because you
don't have anymore data yet.
The scroll bar looks correct and
you can use fast scrollers very
easily because you have the
entire data set presented to the
recycler view so you can jump
anywhere.  And another nice
feature is you don't
have to implement the loading
spinner at
the bottom because the users can
see
it and know the item is still
loading.  It's important that
your items stay the same size.
If you can't guess what the item
height is going to be before you
have
content, the cross animation
doesn't look great.
The adapter have to handle null
items.  And then your data
source has to be
able to count items.  If you're
using something that is
loading data from say the
network, your
back end may not be able to
provide a precise count.
So we have been talking about
live
data thus far but as Yigit
introduced we
also want to support our RxJava
developers.
You may want to produce an
observable
and we provide the class Rx
paged list builder to do exactly
that.  You can change the return
type here
use an Rx page list builder and
specifically
request observable or flowible
out of it.
Now let's go under the hood
because we have shown how small
of a code change this can be to
change the paging library but
how does that work underneath?
Here on the left you have the
repository that represents the
data loading portion of your
application and then on the
right you have the view
model which is how it
communicates to the UI.
Inside the repository we want to
produce something that will push
updates to the UI.
When you call live paged list
builder.
build, we want the producer side
as well.
Once someone starts observing
that
live data we will create a new
page list because that's the way
we start passing information
down this pipeline and to do
that we create a new data source
out of
the factory that it's able to
produce.
To pass this page list over we
want don't want to send an empty
list.  We would like to load
data first and
we do that on a background
thread, initialize the data and
create a page list out of it.
The first page list we produced
has data only in the very front.
We can send that to the UI
thread
.  Submit this to the adapter
and adapter can start presenting
those items.
We might need to load more data
so the page list internally will
trigger a data load from its
data source.
And append that data directly to
the page list.
Now the cross fade animation
occurs because we have signaled
the recycler
view that these new items are
updated
again but what happens
when if the database says this
table has been validated
something changed, we invalidate
it so let's look at what happens
in order to start pushing those
updates from the other side.
So on the other side of things
we can see the database had an
item added to
it, that's why we invalidated
the
previous data source and the
producer
side is listening to the signal
to say we need a new page list.
We can create a new page list to
send over.
When we load the initial data we
are careful to initialize that
based on the
loading position that was
signaled by the adapter.
We send that over to the UI.
And now we submit list again.
Because these are two different
lists
and we really don't want to call
notify
data set changed we compute
an a synchronous dif.
Immediately you get a new item
showing up and we only have to
do the minimal amount of UI work
to bind and show the new item.
So fundamentally under the hood
we do a lot of trickery to make
this work but from the outside
we try and make it look as close
as possible to a live data of a
list because this is a really
nice experience.  It let's you
keep your UI really simple and
avoid all the information
about paging on that side and
let you configure and construct
your flow in one place from the
repository.
The page list adapter let's you
handle
the new pages lists as they flow
in and the internal updates of
the paged list as it loads.
.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Let's talk
about data sources.
So imagine that page list is a
list of implementation that
works with a data source and we
have different types of data
sources.
You can have a positional data
source,
an item keep data source and
page keep data source.
Let's start with with positional
data source.  If you have the
data locally but user may want
to jump into arbitrary
positions, positional data
source is your best option.
This is actually what uses
behind the scenes.  If you have
a data source you extend
this position data source clause
and specify the type of items.
Let's look at an example.
Zoom out, go to the bird's eye
view and have a data source.
The very first time
time come to the recycler view
, page size, start position and
load size which is usually
larger than the page size
because you want to have more
items at the beginning and
whether place holders are
enabled or not.  Our data source
will return the data, tell us
where the data starts and it
will give us total number of
items in the data source.
Based on that we will start
displaying
the data but also display the
place the place holders so the
size of the page is equal to the
total number of items in the
data source.
As soon as user starts
scrolling, it's
going to run out of data and
call this on the positional data
source, the start
position of the first item is
missing,
and page size, and get the new
data appended to the list.
So in this case use the fast
scroller
and jumps into a position where
we don't have data yet.
When this happens it won't call
the data source position.
With a recycler view we load
that page so we can display to
the user.
This is where positional data
sources is really good if user
can jump into arbitrary
positions.  You never block
them.  Let's say something
happened in the
database so we will get a new
data source.  Each data source
represents a snapshot of the
data.
So we get this new one, we
create new pages for it and load
the initial page
from this data source based on
where user is in the previous
one.  We will bring this one as
always on a background thread
and calculate the difference
between these two lists and
update the recycler view with
the correct animations.
Second one is the item keyed
data source.
Imagine you have data like a
list with some names.
If you look at the page out of
this, you can identify the items
before this page by using the
first item in the list and then
the next page by using the last
item in the list.
Basically every item can
identify a page after or before
it.
If your data source is like that
you
should implement the item keep
data source clause.  You provide
the key type.  In this case we
are using names so string and
item type in the list.
Let's get an example.  So first
time you come to the recycler
view, let's call
the load initial method, request
initial key, request load size
and place
holders enabled.  Data source
will only return this data, it's
not going to count it because
there's no place holders.  As
soon as users start scrolling we
will extract a key from the last
item we
have and call the data source
load after method to load that
other page.
Similarly as user keeps
scrolling
and then loads another page the
same way.
Now at this point let's say the
data is coming from the
database, similarly something
has changed so we lost that data
source.  Minimal data.
We will get the new data source
by recreating new page list, we
are going to extract the key
from one of the items
that is currently visible in the
recycler view and load the page
from this new data source.
And we get that page, we
understand these are pages, we
will calculate the
dif and update the UI with the
correct animations.
Now, we don't have the data on
top
anymore so if user tries to
scroll up we need more data.
Same thing, you just take the
key from
the last item, call load, get
that page appended to the page
list and now user can scroll
upwards.
This is always lazy, always
reactive.
Third one is the page keyed data
source.  This is a really common
way of paging especially on the
server side APIs.
Your client sends a question and
when the response comes from the
server it
include the data and also
includes
pointers for the next and
previous keys.
So if you have a data source
like that you should implement
the page key data
source, specify the type of keys
using the pointers and item
type.  Let's look at an example.
First time user comes
comes, we called load initial,
give it
a size and ask whether place
holders enabled or not.
We will assume disabled, easier.
And then the data source turns
the
data but also gives us pointers
for the previous key and the
next page key.
Let me start displaying it.
If user scrolls, we need more
contact
so we are going to call the load
after method, use the key that
was returned in the previous
request to get the next page
from the data source.
Now this next page comes with a
field called adjacent page key.
It's like a list of pages.
You take that, user can scroll.
Now the difference in this data
source
is how we have the invaldation.
Hit the refresh button on the
screen,
we will get the new data source,
but in the load initial method
there's no key anymore.
This is because I mentioned it's
like a link list so if the
previous list is invalid, links
in the list doesn't mean
anything.  So always need to log
the very first page again and
display to the UI.  This is
usually not a problem in
practice because you only do
this if user does swipe to
refresh so they're already on
top of the list.
the list.
>> CHRIS CRAIK: You talked
through what
we might see
implementing a data source but
what if
we want multiple sources at
once.  You can page from your
back end that you have with all
the benefits of the local cache.
You can have a really nice off
line
support, you can resume quickly
if the application has been
killed and
restarted and you can minimize
network traffic by taking
advantage of data already on
device.  Let's look at how this
might look compared to what we
were showing before with a
single source of data.  How does
the network fit into the system?
One way that we could do this is
we could say well the network is
my source
of data when I'm connected and
the database is my source when
I'm not.  If I'm connected I
page data from the
network and if I'm not I page
data from the database.
The one problem there is that
you don't have anything storing
data in your database even when
you're loading a
network but it's pretty easy as
a side affect you can load into
the database.  However there's a
couple problems that are
important to discuss.  This
switching model has the first
problem.  This connected state
is really over simplifying.  In
reality individual requests to
your servers can succeed and
fail and a user
that is connected like 20%, some
of the packets go through, that
really doesn't fit nicely into
this model.
The other big problem is we are
not using local data when it's
present.  Let's go about looking
at a different way to do this.
So what if instead we just
monitor the database and use
that as our local
single source of truth.
What we can do is say well the
only times I need to load data
is when the database tells me
it's out of data.  I can use
that as a signal to load more
data from the network, store it
into the database, and then I
have my entire solution built.
I just load data when I need to
but I can present only the
database which makes things a
lot simpler.
So we get the benefits of
consistent data presentation, we
have a similar
process but this degrades on
failures.
If your user is in in 20%
connected state you can use all
the data you have
locally and try and fetch or
retry when the network is
around.  Potentially you might
say this doesn't keep my data
fresh.
An easy way to work around that
is say
when ever anyone starts new data
we start a new fresh.  And
that's especially important
usually when you have frequently
updating data.
So in that proposed model here
that we saw we need an out of
data signal from the database
because the rest of that we
basically already built in the
first few slides.
So when we have that signal we
can trigger loads from the
network directly into the
database and the UI doesn't have
to enter into any of that.
So paging built exactly this
signal for
exactly this reason and we call
the the boundary call back.
Let's look at what that might
look like.
The first most important part of
the boundary call back that you
implement is
that you pass it to -- you want
to provide it two different
sources of data, the database
and the network, because that's
its job.
So the important call back we
have here is on I'm end loaded.
The last item of the database
has been loaded from the paged
list and if there's more from
the network it's time to load
it.
So the first thing that we do in
response to this is over run the
network thread, request the
service hey give me more data.
In this particular case we are
using
the item at the end to feed
which data we need more of
because we are in an item key
case similar to the item key
data source that you saw before.
Now if that request is
successful we we
simply jump over the the
database thread, insert that
data and we are basically done.
We connected that signal that we
needed and now we added network
to
something that was purely
database.  It's possible when
the database is
being invalidated locally for
multiple add end signals to
trigger.  You can protect this
with a simple
boolean to say if I'm already
loading, don't try.
And then we can re-set that at
the end.
So using boundary call back is
pretty simple.
You can add this in your Rx page
list
builder and that gives you the
database
plus network solution all
isolated in that one call back.
Let's talk about what the paging
library is.
So the paging library provides
paging from database network and
importantly both as we just saw
and it can load that data
directly into recycler view.
It extends this live data of
lists, this
observable list pattern that we
like because it keeps our UI
simple and let's us contain all
the complex logic on one side.
It's configurable.
We have configurable load size,
pre-Fitch
and place holders.  1.
0 was just released so
so please try and give it a
spin.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Where to go
next?  We will provide more
details and more samples here.
We have an amazing code lab.
You can change it out in the
code lab area or you can try it
online.
We also have have samples on
GitHub
where we implement different
data sources and you can compare
and contrast the behavior have
different data sources and you
can also see how you can handle
things like errors, retries.
But if you have been sitting
here for
the last 30 minutes and
wondering
whether these two guys never
heard about cursors, rest assure
we did hear about that.  What we
wanted to use initially when we
started this project because we
already have cursor adapters,
courseier takes care of all the
work, right?  Wrong.
It's very unpredictable and
unefficient in your cursor
becomess locked.  Be very
careful.
Room and paging together avoids
this
problem because we create much
smaller queries not to rely on
the paging
behavior of cursors.
There's an amazing blog post
about this that you can watch
the link.  We will post it after
the talk.  It's amazing.
Cursor as paging is not the
right way to the paging.
We did it wrong.
>> CHRIS CRAIK: Did it wrong
ten years ago at least.
>> YIGIT BOYAR: Ten years ago.
But it's not me.  Okay.
[Laughter] so paging is part of
Jetpack.
Our new initiative to accelerate
Android development.  We have
great many talks at this I/O.
This was the last one.  If you
were not able to go all the
sessions check everything on
YouTube, it's recorded.
And you can learning about
Jetpack on our website.  Thank
you.
(Applause)
.
>> Thank you for joining this
session.  Grand ambassadors will
assist with directing you
through the designated exits.
We will be making room for those
who registered for the next
session.  If you registered for
the next session in this room we
ask that you please clear the
room and return via the
registration line outside.
Thank you.
Distributed TensorFlow training.
Training
Distributed TensorFlow Training
.
Distributed TensorFlow training.
Training
.
>> Welcome. Please fill in the
seats near the front of the
room.  Thank you.
Disputed TensorFlow training.
Training
Eps
.
>> At this time please find your
seat.  Our session will begin
soon.
Distributed TensorFlow Training.
.
>> Hello, everyone. Welcome.
What a busy last few days this
has been.
Thank you for being with us
until the very end.  My name is
Priya.
>> ANJALI SRIDHAR: And I'm
Anjali.
>> PRIYA GUPTA: We are on the
TensorFlow team.
We are so excited to be here
today to tell you about
distributed TensorFlow training.
Let me grab the clicker.  Okay.
Hopefully most of you know what
TensorFlow is.  It's an open
source Machine Learning
framework used extensively both
inside and outside Google.
For example if you're trying the
smart compose feature that was
launched a couple days ago, that
feature uses TensorFlow.
TensorFlow allows you to build,
train
and predict using neural such as
this.  In training we learned
the parameters of the network
using data.
Training complex neural networks
with
large amounts of data with often
take a
long time n the graph you can
see the
training time on the X axis and
the accuracy of predictions on
the Y axis
.  As you can see, it took more
than 80 hours to get to 75%
accuracy.  If you have some
experience running complex
Machine Learning models this
might sound rather familiar to
you and
it might make you feel something
like this.
If you're training takes only a
few minutes to a few hours
you'll be productive and happy
and you can try out new ideas
faster.
When it starts the take a few
days, maybe you can manage and
run a few things in parallel.
When it starts to take a few
weeks
your progress will slow down and
it becomes expensive to try out
every new idea.
And when it starts to take more
than a month I think it's not
even worth thinking about.
And this is not an exaggeration.
Training complex models can take
up to
a week on a single but powerful
GPU like a Tesla P 100.
So natural question to ask is
how can we make training fast?
There are a number of things you
can try.
You can use the faster
accelerators such as a TPU.  I'm
sure you've heard all about them
in the last couple of days here.
Your input pipeline might be the
bottle neck.  There are a number
of guidelines on the TensorFlow
website that you can try and
improve the performance or your
training.
In this talk we will talks on
distributed training that is
running training in parallel on
multiple devices
such as CPUs, GPUs, or TPUs in
order to make your training
faster.
With the techniques that we will
talk about in this talk, you can
bring down
your training time from weeks to
hours
with just a few lines of code
and a few powerful GPUs.  In the
graph you can see the images per
second processed while training
an image recognition model.  As
you can see as we increase the
number of GPUs from 1 to 4 to 8,
the
images per second process can
almost double every time.
We will come back to these
performance numbers later.
Before we get into the details
of scaling in TensorFlow, first
I want to
cover a few high level concepts
and architectures in distributed
training.
This will give us a strong
foundation to understand the
various solutions.
As you're focused on training
today, let's take a look at what
a typical training loop looks
like.  Let's say you have a
simple model like
this with a couple of hidden
layers,
each layer has a bunch of of
weights and biases also called
trainable variables.
A training step begins with
processing on the input data but
then feeds this input into the
model and computes the
productions in the forward pass.
We then compare the productions
with
the input label and compare --
compute the locals.
Then in the backward pass we
compute
the gradient and finally we
update the models using the
gradient.
This
is known as one training step.
It repeats until you reach the
desired accuracy.  Let's say you
begin your training with a
simple machine under your desk
with a multi-core CPU.
Luckily TensorFlow handles
scaling for you automatically.
Next you may speed up by adding
an
accelerator to your machine but
distributed training you can go
even further.
You can go from one machine with
a single device to one machine
with
multiple devices and finally to
multiple machines with possibly
multiple devices each connected
over the network.
With a number of techniques
eventually
it's possible to scale to
hundreds of devices and that's
what we do in a lot
of Google systems.  In the rest
of this talk we will use
the terms device, worker or
accelerator to refer to
processing units such as GPUs or
TPUs.
So how does distributed training
work?
There are a number of ways to go
about when you think about
distributing your training.
What approach you pick depends
on tb size of your model, the
amount of training data you
have, and the
available devices.  The most
common architecture and
distributed training is what is
known as data parallelism.  In
data parallelism we run the same
model and computation on each
worker but with a different
slice of the input data.  Each
device computes the loss and
gradient, uses gradients to
updates the model parameters.
And the updated model is used in
the next round of computation.
There are two common approaches
within you think about how do
you update the
models using these gradients.
The first approach is what is
known as async parameter server
approach.
In this approach we designate
some
devices as parameter servers as
shown in blue here.
These servers hold the
parameters of the model.
Others are designated as
workers, as shown in green leer.
Workers do the bulk of the
computation.  Each worker
fetches the parameters
from the parameter server, it
then computes the loss and
gradients, sends the gradients
back to the parameter server
which then updates the models
parameters using these
gradients.
Each worker does this
independently so this allows us
to scale this approach to a
large number of workers.  This
has worked well for many models
in Google where training workers
might be preempted by high
priority production
jobs or where there's asymmetry
between the workers or where
machines might go down for
regular maintenance.  And all of
this doesn't hurt the scaling
because the workers are not
waiting on each other.
The down side of this approach,
however,
is that workers can get out of
sync, they're computing their
gradients on
stale parameter values and this
can delay convergence.
The second approach is what is
known as synchronous allreduce.
This has become more common with
the
rise of fast accelerators such
as TPUs or GPUs.  In this
approach each worker has a copy
of parameters on its own, there
are no special parameter
servers.
Each worker computes the loss
and
gradients based on a subset of
training samples.
Once gradients are computed the
workers communicate among
themselves to propagate the
gradients and update the model
parameters.
All the workers are synchronized
which means the next round of
computation doesn't begin until
each worker received
the updated gradients and
updateed this model.
When you have fast devices in a
controlled environment, the
variants of set time between the
different workers can be small.
When combined with strong
communication links between the
different devices, over all
overhead or synchronization can
be small.  When ever practical
this approach can lead to faster
conversions.
A class of algorithms called
allreduce
can be used to efficiently
combine the gradients across the
different workers.
By adding them up and then
copying them
to the different workers, it's a
fused
algorithm that can be very
efficient.
There are many allreduce
algorithms available depending
on the time of communication
available between the different
workers.
One common algorithm is what is
known as ring allreduce.
Each worker sends gradients and
receives gradients from
its predecessor.
At the end of of the algorithm
each worker has received a copy
of the combined gradient.
Ring allreduce uses network
Bandwidth optimally.
It can also overlap the gradient
computation at lower layers in
the network with transmission of
gradients at the higher layers
which means it can further
reduce the training time.  Ring
allreduce is just one approach
and
one approach.  We have a team in
Google working on
fast implementations of
allreduce for various device
topologys.
The bottom line is allreduce can
be fast when working with
multiple devices on a single
machine or a small number of
machines.
So given these two architectures
and data parallelisms you may be
wondering which approach should
you pick.  There isn't one right
answer.  Parameter server
approach is preferable if you
have a large number of
not so powerful or not so
reliable machines.  If you have
a large cluster of machines with
just CPUs.
The synchronous allreduce
approach is
is preferible if you have --
parameter server approach has
been around for a
while and has been supported
well.  TPUs use allreduce
approach out of the box.
In the next section of this talk
we will show you how you can
scale your training
using the allreduce approach on
multiple GPUs with just a few
lines of code.
Before I get into that I just
want to mention another type of
distributed training known as
model parallelism that you may
have heard of.
A simple way to think about
model
parallelism is when your model
is so big that it doesn't fit in
the memory of one device so you
divide the model into
smaller parts and through those
computations on different
workers with the same training
samples.  For example, you could
put different
layers of your model on
different devices.  These
however most devices have big
enough memory that most models
can fit in their memory.  So in
the rest of this talk we will
continue to focus on data
parallelism.
Let's see how you can do this
TensorFlow.
As I already
mentions we are going to focus
on multiple GPUs with the
allreduce architecture.  I'm
pleased to introduce the new
distribution strategy API.
This allows you to distribute
your training in TensorFlow with
very little modification to your
code.
The distribution strategy API
you no
longer need to place your ops or
parameters on specific devices.
You don't need to worry about
structuring your modeling in a
way that
the gradients or losses across
devices are aggregated
correctly.  Distribution
strategy does that for you.
It is easy to use and fast to
train.
Now let's look at some code to
see how you can do this API.
In our example we are going to
be using
TensorFlow's high level API call
estimator.
If you've used this API before
you might be familiar with the
following
snippet of code to create a
custom estimator.  It requires
three argument also.
The first one is a function that
defines your model so defines
the parameters of your model,
how you compute the loss and the
gradients and how you update the
model's parameters.  The second
argument is the directory where
you wants to persist the state
of your model.  And the third
argument is a
configuration call run con fig
where you can specify things.
In this case we used the default
run config.
Wujs you create the estimator
you can
start your training by kaug the
train method with the input
function that provides your
training data.
Given this code to do the
training on
one device, how can you change
it to run on multiple GPUs?
You simply need to add one line
of code.  Something called
mirrored strategy and pass it to
the run config.  That's all the
code changes you need to scale
this code to multiple GPUs.
Mirrored strategy is a type of
distribution strategy API that I
just mentioned.
For this API you don't need to
make
any changes to your model
function or input function or
training loop.  You don't need
to specify your devices.  If you
want to run on all available
devices it will automatically
detect that and run your
training on all available GPUs.
So that's it.  Those are all the
code changes you need.
This API is available and you
can try it out today.
Let me quickly talk about what
mirror strategy does.
Mirrored strategy implements the
synchronous allreduce
architecture that we talked
about out of the box for you.
In mirrored strategy the model's
parameters are mirrored across
devices hence the name mirrored
strategy.
Each device computes the last
end gradient based on a subset
of the input data.
The gradients are aggregated
across the workers using an
allreduce algorithm that is
appropriate for your device
topology.
As I already mentioned with
mirrored strategy you don't need
to make any changes to your
model or your training loop.
This is because we have changed
line components of TensorFlow to
be distribution aware.
For example, optimizer,
summaries, et cetera.
You don't need to make any
changes to your input function
as long as you're
using the recommended TensorFlow
data set API.  You can save with
within or no distribution
strategy and resume with
another.  And summaries work as
expected as well
so you can continue to visualize
your
training
in TensorFlow.
I'll now hand it off to Anjali
to show
you cool demos and performance
numbers.  (Applause).
>> ANJALI SRIDHAR: Thanks,
Priya, for the great
introduction to mirrored
strategy.  Before we run the
demo, let's get familiar with a
few configurations.
I'm going to be running the res
net 50
model from
the TensorFlow model garden.
It uses fit connections for
every gradient flow.
The TensorFlow model garden is a
repo
where there are a collection of
gardens.  If you're new to
TensorFlow this is a great
resource to start with.  I'm
going to be using the image net
data set as input to model
training.  It's a collection of
over a million images that have
been categorized into a
thousands labels.
I'm going
to intansate the N 1 standard
and Tesla V 100.  Let's run the
demo now.
As I mentioned I'm creating an N
standard instance attaching
eight in
video Tesla V
Nvidia Tesla V 100.
To run our TensorFlow model we
need to
install a few drivers and
packages and
here is a gist with all the
commands required.
I'm going to make this public so
you can set up an instance
yourself and try running the
model.
Let's open an SSH connection to
the
instance by clicking on a button
here.  This should bring up a
terminal like this.
I've already cloned the garden
model repo.  We are going to be
running this
command inside the res net
director
.  We are are going to run the
image net main fail.
A model director is going to
point  Batch size of 1024 or 128
per GPU.
to the bucket.  We point our
data director to the SSD disk
writ has the image net data set
and the number of GPUs is eight
of which we want to be able to
train you're model.
So lets run this model now.
Let's take a look at some of the
code
changes that are involved to
change the res net model
function.  This is the res net
main function in the garden
model repo.
First we instantiate the
strategy and pass it to the run
config.
We create an estimator object
with the
run config and then
and those are all the code
changes you need to distribute
the res net model.  Let's go
back and see how our training is
going.
So we have run for a few hundred
steps.
At the bottom of the screen you
could see the metrics.  Let's
look at tensor board.  This is
from a run where I've run the
model for 90 thousands steps.
The orange and red lines are the
training and evaluation losses.
So as the number of steps very
you see the loss decreasing.
Let's look at evaluation
accuracy and
this is when we are training res
net 50 over eight GPUs.
Around 91,000 steps we are able
to achieve a 75% accuracy.
Let's see what this looks like
when we
write on a single GPU so let's
toggle the tensor board buttons
on the left and look at the lost
cause.
So the blue lines are one GPU
and red and orange are eight.
You can see the loss doesn't
decrease as rapidly as it does
with eight GPUs.
Here are
the evaluation accuracy codes.
Let's compare using wall time.
So we run the same model nor the
same amount of time.  And when
we run it over multiple GPUs we
are able to achieve higher
accuracy
facility accuracy faster or
train our model faster.
Let's look at a few performance
benchmarks on the DGX one.  It's
a machine on which1.  It's a
machine on which we run deep
learning models.
We are running mixed precision
training with a batch size of
256.
It also has V 100 GPUs.
So the graph shows X axis the
number of GPUs on the X axis and
images per second on the Y axis.
As we go from one GPU to eight
we are
able to achieve a speed up of 7
X. 8 we are able to achieve a
speed up of 7 X.  And this is
performance right out of the box
with no tuning.  We are actively
working on improving performance
so that you're able to
achieve more speed up and get
more images per second when you
distribute your model across
multiple GPUs.
So far we have been talking
about the core part of model
training and distributing your
model using mirrored strategy.
Let's say now you deployed your
model on multiple GPUs.
You're going to expect to see
the same kind of boost in images
per second when do you that but
you may not be able to view as
many images the second as xarld
to one GPU.
You may not see the boost in
performance and the reason for
that is
often the input pipelinecompared
to one GPU.  You may not see the
boost in performance and the
reason for that is often the
input pipeline.
Run you run your model on a
single GPU
the input pipeline is
preprocessing the data and
making it available for
training.
But GPUs process and compute
data much faster than a CPU.
This means that when you
distribute your model across
multiple GPUs, the input
pipeline is often not able to
keep up with the training.
It quickly becomes a bottle
neck.  For the rest of the talk
I'm going to
show you how TensorFlow makes it
easy
for you to use data to build
efficient input pipelines.
Here is a simple input pipeline
for res net 50.
We are going to use TF.
data APIs.  When you have lots
of data and different data
formats and you want to perform
complex transformations on this
data you want to be using
tf.data APIs to build your
pipeline.  First get the list of
input files that contain your
image and labels.  Then we are
going to read these files
use the tf record data set
reader.  We are going to shuffle
the records.
Repeat them a few times
depending on if you want to run
your model for a
couple of epochs and finally
apply a map transformation.
This
process transformation center,
and
finally batch the input and into
a batch size that you desire.
The input pipeline can be
thought of
as an ETL process as an ETL
process.  In the extract phase
we are reading from storage.
In the transform phase we are
applying
the different transformations.
And finally in the load phase we
are providing this process data
to the accelerator for training.
So how does this apply to the
example that we just saw?
In the extract phase we list the
files
and read it using the tf.
data record data set
.  And finally in the load phase
we tell
TensorFlow how to grab the data
from the
data set.
This is what our input pipeline
looks like.
We have the action the extract,
transform and load phases
happening sequentially.  This
means when the CPU is busy
preprocessing the data the
accelerator is idle.  When the
accelerateor is training the
model the CPU is idle.
But the different phases of the
ETL
process use different hardware
sources.
.  The training happens on the
accelerator.
So if we can parallelize these
different phases, then we can
have the preprocessing of data
on the CPU with training of the
model on the GPU.  This is
called pipelining.
So we can use pipelining and
some parallelizeation techniques
to build
more efficient input pipelines.
Let's look at a few of these
techniques.
First you can parallelize file
reading.
Let's say you have a lot of data
across the cloud storage
service.
You want to read multiple files
in
parallel and you can do this use
can the num parallel reads.
This allows you to increase your
effective.
We can also parallelize map
function
for transformations.  The
different transformation for the
map function by using the num
parallel calls argument.
Typically the argument may
provide a
number of calls of the CPU.
And finally you want
to call pre-fetch at the end of
your pipeline.  You can buffer
data for the next training step
while the accelerator is still
training the current step.
This is what we had before.  And
this is what we can get an
improvement on.
Here the different phases of the
input pipeline are happening in
parallel with training.
We are able to see the CPU is
preprocessing data in step two
while
the training step is still in
step one.
The training time is now a
maximum of preprocessing and
training on the accelerator.  As
you can see the accelerator is
still not 100% utilized.
There are few advanced
techniques that improve this.
We can use fused transformation
ops for some of these API calls.
Shuffle and repeat, for example,
can
be replaced by fused op.
So this parallelizes buffering,
epoch and plus one.
We can also replace map and
batch with equivalent fused op.
This parallelizes the map
transformation with adding the
input tensors to batch.
With these techniques we are
able to process data much faster
and make t
available to the accelerator for
training and improve the
training speed.
it available to the accelerator
for training and improve the
training speed.
I hope this gives you a good
idea of
how you can use APIs to build
efficient input pipelines when
you train your model.
So far we have been talking
about training on a single
machine and multiple devices.
What if you wanted to train on
multiple machines?
You can use the estimators train
and evaluate API.
Train and evaluate API using the
async parameter server approach.
This API is used widely within
Google
and it scales well to a large
number of machines.  Here is a
link to the API where you can
learn more on how to use it.
We are also excited to be
working on a
number of new distribution
strategies.  We are working on a
multi machine mirrored strategy.
We are also working on adding
distribution strategy support to
TPUs
and directly in tf.Keras.  In
this talk we talked about the
different concepts related to
distributed training
architectures and API.
When you go home today here are
three things to keep in mind
when you train your model.
Distribute your training to make
it faster.
To do this, you want to use
distribution strategy APIs.
They're easy to use and fast.
Input pipeline performance is
important
.
Here are a few TensorFlow
resources.  First we have the
distribution strategy API.
You can try using mirrored
strategy to
train your model across multiple
GPUs.
Here is a link to the res net 50
model garden example so you can
try running this example.
It has mirrored strategy API
support enabled.
Here is a link also to the input
pipe
lin
performance guide which has more
techniques you can use to build
efficient pipelines.
And here is the link to the gist
that I mentioned in the demo.
You can try setting up your on
instance and running the res net
50 model garden example.
So this is a combined effort
involving a lot of folks on the
TensorFlow team and we are
really excited to be heading in
this direction.  We are happy to
take questions off line near the
community meet up spot.  Thank
you for attending our talk and
we hope you had a great I/O.
(Applause)
.
(Session concluded)